We brought customers
to Joe Rogan.net.
Did it again?
Fucking idiot.
I'm not a good spokesperson for weed.
I'm really not.
I mean I am and I'm not at the same
time.
You could use a lot of what I do against
me.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net and click on
the link for the flashlight and entering
the code name,
Rogan,
you will get 15 percent off of the
number one adult sex toys for men.
Oh Shit.
Would that said
fuck a lot bitches.
Brian counts in the motherfucking house.
Oh,
you're going to experience
Brian Kaylin,
my friend.
Good to be here.
Glad to be here.
My friend who at one point in time
stopped doing standup boy.
I remember that.
The dark days,
the dark days of hanging out with
actors.
So long time,
two years mother fuckers.
They got you.
Gotcha.
With other stupid silliness,
but he's in character.
Hold on it.
Got You.
You started wanting to be like them.
You wanted to be accepted.
You want to be cool.
I want to make believe for A.
I just want to be down before we even
get started.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're at Cobb's comedy club this
weekend.
It's me,
Tommy and Sam triple.
If you've never seen tom or Sam,
they're both fucking awesome dudes.
Some of the funniest guys working today.
And uh,
I have my cobb's comedy club Mug here.
My 25th anniversary.
I've never been.
If you're a San Francisco person or
anywhere in the north west of count,
what is it?
Northwest California,
whatever.
Northern California.
It's fucking great club.
It's a real,
a club where they really,
you know,
Tom,
the guy who runs it really honors the
art of standup.
He really loves it.
There's a few clubs like that,
you know,
there's Wendy in Denver and this,
there's a few all throughout the country
with the,
the owner,
the person who runs it really love
standup and that's one of them.
So being as corporate sort of,
you know,
fuck,
yeah,
that's it.
Well,
you know what I've got to tell you,
you know,
people will complain about the Improv's
I never see.
I think they're great.
They can clean,
they take care of everything.
It's run really well.
It's,
it's pretty cool
sweater.
Oh,
is that me?
Yeah.
Oh,
I thought it was on.
Um,
um,
yeah,
you know,
the thing is they guarantee you a good
show.
It's guaranteed they're going to be
taking care of the room.
They're going to be making sure there's
no hecklers.
The waitresses are all will be well
trained,
the Dj all beyond on point.
It's all the same experience.
It's just a little bit of different
staff,
different staff.
And you know,
in Kentucky it's like they put emphasis
on the fact that they go,
if you come here and pay a premium,
you're going to laugh your ass off for
two hours.
They're going to do,
we're going to do a good job.
They know what the fuck they're doing
and there's a lot of them,
you know,
but it's one of those good chains,
people go,
oh,
what's up mom and pop clubs does.
It is,
it really is,
is it ever put out one?
And even if the,
even if it does,
maybe those mom and pop one socked,
right?
Why can they compete?
That's the question.
Well,
the problem is I do hear that they do
this.
When they tell you you can't work the
other club.
Well I,
I'm a member.
I'm they levity represents me and I love
them.
They financed my one hour just recently.
They take some levity is the people that
owned.
But Robert Procurement owns a lot of
men.
He's a personal friend.
And I'm going to tell you something
right now.
I'm not saying just because I'm going to
put the podcasts.
That guy's a great guy,
great guy.
He loves comedy is very competitive.
I don't mind that.
I mean,
but.
But I think at the end of the day those
guys are there.
They're there.
I would have said that they,
they only let you do the Improv.
The fact that I have a different booking
agent now who's fantastic.
I'm Justin Edberg over at super
entertainment.
I get,
I get to do any club I want and he books
me out anywhere I want.
So if you're with them,
any pressure to not only do the uh,
you know,
I didn't know that I had when I was at
Gersh.
Gersh had some secret deal.
Sure.
Info.
Exactly.
It was really creepy because other clubs
would tell me like a few of them would
say,
Hey,
I've been trying to book you forever and
I could never booked you.
And I'd be like,
really?
You know,
I never heard any of this.
I never got any of the deals like
Nashville and never did Nashville when I
was with.
There was a lot of clubs,
but they just would ignore me because
they have a relationship.
They develop and they cherish those
relationships because they can get more
bang for their buck.
It's always gonna happen.
But what I did is that's why you
separate the powers.
That's why you get a booking agent who's
going to make his own money on you in
his own way.
Isn't it sort of.
There's a fucking dance man between big
business,
which you can't have a fucking society
like this without a big business.
That extends from comedy clubs until,
let me pretty much anything.
Let me give you example of why that's
good and why it's bad you you.
Let's take,
for example,
have you noticed that when you travel
the country,
there aren't a lot of restaurants that
are locally owned,
so in other you don't see a lot of mom
and pop restaurants with character.
Lot of times you go into a place and
you've got hooters,
applebee's,
no.
Why?
What happened?
I don't want to eat that kind of food.
Personally.
I don't really like that kind of food.
I'd rather have something with
character.
It's one of the reasons I live,
you know,
what I like about New York or even
Venice doubt and you're so busy humean
variables but,
but it.
But it's individual expression and you
know,
people from Venice named cook their own
food.
I liked the.
I appreciate that too.
And there's something about that.
That's fun.
Absolutely.
But,
but what's happened I think is that we
have a very litigious societies,
you know?
Right.
So if you open it for stupid,
that means people are too soupy.
But show you.
Sorry for you young kids,
I'm really bombastic.
That means I would use sling those words
around,
so what happened is it bad?
So.
So if you open a restaurant,
so when he gets food poisoning and they
sue you,
you,
you're,
you're a lot of times you better have
really good insurance because keeping up
with those medical bills,
if two people get to,
you know,
get a for people,
get a cola or whatever it might be,
and you have a local restaurant,
we'll see later.
The reason that a lot of these
restaurants take a chance of opening up.
It's very hard to make a restaurant work
anyway.
The reason you,
you opened a restaurant,
if you're pf Chang's,
you've got deep pockets and you become a
corporation.
You can withstand any kind of bullshit
you deal with when it comes to lawsuits,
food poisoning or what are they
franchises
or they all protected under the same
umbrella financially,
legally.
Both actually the mother corporation
that will create these subsidiaries so
that they do get sued.
They can't come after the mother
corporation.
So that's Kinda how it works.
But they got deep pockets financing
everything.
I do appreciate in the mom and pop
aspect of it,
but you know also when you're in a town
you'd like to go to best buy and know if
you need a fucking lap price.
Everything has a price you want Walmart,
it brings tvs down to $26,
but but you're gonna pay a price in some
ways and how has that.
One example is main street used to
spring up organically in the American
city,
right?
You got main street and he had a bunch
of little shops and those shops were
passed down generation to generation.
Everybody knew each other.
There's something very charming and
wonderful about that,
but guess what?
That costs money.
It is not as efficient as say target on
one side,
Walmart on the other,
but you pay a price in another way.
In my opinion,
anonymity,
you're surrounded by beige walls.
You have no connection to a continuum.
You tell me the difference between
Kansas City a lot of times and Columbia,
Missouri,
when you,
when you walk down the street that we're
becoming a very generic looking place
and have and the experiences generic you
want to go shopping,
you go to an outdoor mall or an indoor
mall depending on the weather and,
and you're gonna find the same exact
stores everywhere you go.
Sure you can get anything you want,
but what at what price?
But it's a little bit like you,
you buy food for texture and not taste
and you want a real taste in food.
It takes a lot of time.
It takes a lot of time in the kitchen to
prepare.
Some people don't care about thinking of
a lot of food.
I love the show,
no reservations.
One of my favorite shows,
we're talking about it on the podcast
all the time and one of the things he
did was he went to New York City and he
went to all the really,
really old places where they own the
building and it's a family.
He went to this Italian,
uh,
owned restaurant Slash Deli.
That's,
I kinda wish I remembered the name
because I haven't saved on the DVR.
It's so good.
That shows the best show on television
that Anthony Bourdain,
Anthony Bourdain.
It's the best show on television and no,
no,
if,
ands or buts.
It's consistently excellent.
He's on point.
I just,
I love the way that guy thinks,
the way he.
He really loves like you went to South
Boston to this awesome episode on South
Boston and the way he fucking loves like
a town,
like a real town which South Boston is
and he went to these places in New York
and this one Italian bakery or it's like
a deli but not a bakery.
It's got everything,
you know,
it's like all these canned meats and
like,
like a meat hanging from dried meats and
cheese hanging from the ceiling and shit
like.
And the guy who was running it had been
working there since he was a baby and he
was in his eighties.
He was old as fuck.
His whole family had been by that.
That,
that,
that is what we're losing this country.
That is exactly the thing is they,
they,
the only way they could do this as if
the one they're stubborn old Italians,
which is a family business.
Then I got rid of the family.
Really?
Why are we getting there to the family
business they do in the end,
you know,
and they own the building.
They've owned the building forever,
so that's the only reason why these
exist and it was a fascinating thing to
watch and the fucking food looks.
So they had spaghetti with meatballs.
All my God,
I want to go make the spaghetti with
meatballs.
I was like,
do I have the wrong gate for the house?
Do I have breadcrumbs?
What the fuck can I do where I can walk
into a store like that?
And you smell a smell.
It's hard to explain if someone lives in
Columbus,
Ohio,
right?
Like where you're from,
that's all.
That's all city,
right?
Isn't it?
Well,
there's definitely a lot of miles,
but you also have like a lot of amish
people.
So you have like the Amish restaurants
and you do have like a different kind of
know the homage.
They can really cook up a pie.
I know how to fuck to like rabbits with
beards,
ladies and gentlemen,
rabbits with beards.
The weirdest thing about the amish.
Did you ever see that documentary where
they.
What's the thing they do called rum
scale or something like that?
I guess when they're graduated from high
school,
they're allowed to go nutty.
They nutty and then one time in their
life.
Yeah,
they get to,
they get to party,
they go crazy.
They go off,
they party,
they fuck,
they go nutty,
and then they basically hit like
spiritual emptiness,
like the full bore,
like all at once,
crash out most of America.
So from every single trash,
meth and cocaine haze and then they go,
I'm coming back to the church where
everyone loves me.
They're really literally completely
unprepared.
If you grow up in the amish community
and you know,
it's a very different kind of life.
It's really weird.
It's cultish.
Youtube to a community and a strong
community with history and also I think
it's really easy.
It's a lot easier in some ways to grow
up that way because you're,
you're,
you're given a your boundaries and the
way to behave and the blueprint for how
to live your life is laid out for you.
A lot of times we grow up in this
country with no blueprint.
You've got to kind of make it up as you
go along,
but it's a funny blueprint and you must
dress like Johnny Cash and not use
electricity to the kind of blueprint is
up,
man.
It's true.
That's a weird blueprint.
They smelled too,
man,
as a kid.
Hey,
generalization,
going to be racist against the 12
online.
We had field trips to like the zoo and
amusement parks and they would go and
buy like buses and that's one thing as a
child growing up,
you were like,
who are these weird people dressed weird
shit was like doh and hard work.
The hell's going on here.
And they were also busted a lot for like
having raised and stuff all the time in
Columbus.
So yeah,
like where they would catch a bunch of
Amish people in a barn somewhere with a
bunch of ecstasy.
Like they.
They're not all this innocence that or
whatever it's called.
God,
I would have to find the name of that
because it's dragged grunge scalar.
Nobody as you can grow up a certain way,
but once you put an idea in somebody's
head,
hey,
this feels really good.
It's really Rumspringa.
That's what it's called.
It's very difficult to to stop human
nature and human nature.
When you push in one direction,
they pull in another.
I see it with my daughter and I see it
with the three year old.
It's fascinating watching a little human
being developed and one of the things
you know and you have a daughter the
same age,
you know,
you'll,
you'll know what I'm talking about.
Like you can see where when you tell
them not to do things,
they want automatically to do it.
It's like it's so ingrained.
It's not something that you teach a
baby,
they just,
it's autumn,
it's already in there.
There's a contrarian streak and a human
being.
It's why any,
anytime you see in any government
experiment in history,
in any society where it's a monarchy and
oligarchy,
uh,
you know,
whether it's a collective as sort of
NATO,
we're all going to behave this way and
these are the rules.
People rebel.
It never really works.
It has to.
That's a part of what has made a human
being a human being.
It's getting coded into our genetics,
unquestionably.
And this,
the reason why Catholic girls are
whores,
it's so simple.
When I was in high school,
all the Catholic girls were slots.
We all knew it and we would joke about
it because in Catholic School,
oh shits,
we'd go,
fuck,
she's in Catholic school.
You knew that when you got that bitch
alone and stuck a finger in her,
she was going to go crazy in your car.
Grab Your Dick.
Like it was a rope hanging over a canyon
and she fell out of an airplane.
Just caught it before sudden death,
like fucking sylvester stallone in
cliffhanger.
And she's going to milk that Dick.
Oh,
like it's the sweetest elixir I had a
girl was telling me about her
relationship with the Lord.
She got nice.
We had an argument which was fun and uh,
and we had an argument and I quickly
realized it was,
you know,
she didn't have a whole lot to base this
on.
It was just kind of.
She had gone through some kind of a
crisis and then last on the Lord,
I banged her in her car to our theater
in.
I'm sorry,
in my car,
I never forgot this.
He was like,
oh,
I can't believe that.
Oh yeah,
I know.
I can't,
I can't either,
but we have a connection.
We connect it.
That's why all the religious girls are.
I mean,
all the horrors back in high school now
are religious.
If you notice,
like I used to be so Douchey,
I have an,
an ultimate confession to make when any,
whenever the subject of religion would
come up,
I was that guy.
I would be so douchey where I'd be like
insulting to you if you believe
something silly.
It would be not just dismissive,
but insulting.
It was such a star because it was,
no one's doing anything bad to me,
but what it is is there's something
about you,
especially when I was young,
when I was 18,
I was really considering religion at one
point in time.
I was very lost.
I was going to join the army.
Uh,
I was doing taekwondo and I heard the
army had a big taekwondo team,
was this kid named Clayton,
I think Clayton Barber,
the,
that might not be his name,
but he was a high level taekwondo guy
that fought for the army.
And I was like,
wow,
they pay for him to fight.
All have to do is give them some cushy
office job and then he gets a train all
the time.
So I was thinking about that and uh,
I was terrified of religion.
I was terrified.
Like whenever I'd fight someone and I
knew that there were Christian,
I would get really nervous because they
had,
they had sort of,
they believed and they had a sort of
inner strength I would have ever.
Right.
What if there's a God with God's looking
out for them?
I really would think that,
like,
I remember one time this guy,
he was sitting on the sidelines on one
knee reading a fucking Bible before we
fund.
Put that book away.
You Fuck?
Put that book like he was going to use
them in.
Holy Ghost was nervous,
man.
I got nervous,
but you know what that does.
I think what the power of any kind of
religion or anything,
anytime you try to go beyond that,
what you can measure.
I think a lot of belief has to do with
less to do with superstition and more to
do.
It's Kinda the same inspiration.
So the the same way you listen to a
piece of music that gets you pumped to
go do something.
I think people can derive the same kind
of strength and inspiration from
scripture or whatever it was.
I know they do.
I know I have a good friend and I'm not
going to talk about him,
but he's very religious and a lot of
people would be shocked,
but he's a pretty strict Catholic and
he's a good friend.
I just let him do his thing.
Man,
you know it's on him.
You know,
that's what would keep them happy,
but when I was young I was so douchey
about it and really it was somehow or
another,
it was because I was insecure that a,
maybe they were writing or,
or be there when I was really young,
but then I started reading religious
history and go,
oh,
wait a minute.
Oh,
this is craziness.
I didn't know I still.
But what fascinates me is I,
I read a whole thing on the origins of
Christianity.
It's pretty interesting.
And,
and,
but I,
I came to St Louis and I went,
what?
That's really,
if you really look at the,
the um,
how much Christ actually said that you
can put it on a,
on a four by four card,
but not a lot.
And then you had all these other,
these followers and call for example,
every met him and had this conversion on
the road to Damascus and wrote all these
letters.
The question becomes why though did
those ideas last 2000 years and a lot of
ideas did.
And that's what I always fascinates me
because we killed the most people.
What sense that simple,
the Christians killed them.
It literally is that.
Actually,
I don't agree with that because you
could say the same.
Same thing about fascism and to kill a
lot of people,
but that,
that kind of.
By the way,
since the Muslims had kicked the ass
that the Christians did,
we would all be learning that omahamed
was the thing and we wouldn't be
celebrating Christmas with.
You're celebrating some walk around the
big box.
No,
but I do think that there is some.
There is a resilience to things like
love,
love thy enemy and unforgiveness.
I know that's true,
Brian,
but you have to understand that all of
this stuff is rehashing old shit.
I don't have to tell you that and the
reason why we are immersed in
Christianity's because this epoch,
this world that we're living in,
we're dealing with a very small amount
of time.
It seems like an enormous amount of time
for us,
but the amount of time that the
Christian religion has dominated the
earth is not the same amount of time.
That back when the Romans were
dominating shit or the Greeks were
dominating shit.
They had a couple of thousand years on
us.
How much we've only been around for a
couple hundred years or you know,
this country in the world,
the world of Christianity,
Lewis,
2000 years.
But let me ask you a question.
How much do you think,
how it seems like human beings always
had this sort of need for to impose
their own forms of self restriction and
discipline and they think it's an
operating system.
Do you think that's a part of our human
nature,
but you think that's a natural function
of.
I think it's very simple.
I think that we're evolving and we are
in an adolescent stage of evolution and
we are something that's in the middle.
We are not quite animal.
We know that we are animal.
We know we interact with animals,
we know we have feelings for animals,
but we also know that they're not us.
We know where something different.
Even from monkeys.
There's a reason why you're allowed to
keep monkeys in the zoo,
but you can't have a slave.
It's because we make some sort of a
distinction that we are something
different from them and people will say,
well,
that's stupid.
We're not.
It's wrong.
You know,
animals have rights.
Honestly,
they don't.
Here's the deal.
If it wasn't for us being so super
smart,
they'd all have eaten us.
It's really that simple.
There's some crazy weird survival thing
going on and the only way to truly be
happy as you have to be on whatever team
you're is,
if you're a dog and you're ratting out
all these other dogs and then the people
running around in club,
the dogs that death in front of you,
you'll be assured you'll feel terrible
so you don't get in trouble with Joe.
Rogan is not talking about racist and
white black or he's talking about human
rights here.
Yes,
I'm talking about.
I'm talking about animals over other
species.
I'm talking about the human race as a
whole.
We're in some weird thing where we're
not quite an animal anymore.
We're an animal,
but we're self aware.
We need food.
We need animal protein,
we need vegetable protein,
we need water.
We need all the things that are regular
biological unit needs to keep itself
alive,
so then,
but we also have some weird awareness
and evolution for you is not just
biological,
it's not just mathematics and bio
biology.
It is,
it is.
We're also evolving from a consciousness
for sure.
I mean and and biologists will argue
with you over the semantics,
over the word evolution saying the
evolution only pertains to a biological
thing that you don't have like evolution
of culture.
You have advancement of culture and you
know,
you have it,
you know,
advanced levels of complexity.
It's,
but it's not technically evolution,
but we all know what the word evolution
means and it's a better word for it.
I don't mind using anything that I
haven't think societies and even the
world as a whole develops a,
their own sort of sense of self
awareness.
We are very aware of what the pitfalls
of,
of how to get,
how you get you fall into things like
genocide.
I do think the world has less brutal as
a whole today.
Way More,
way more.
It's hard for us to understand.
I always try to relate this to people
when we talk about the,
the,
you know,
like people,
like I've had so many conversations,
like,
you know,
I'm Alex Jones is a good friend of mine
and Alex Jones will tell you that right
now that the CIA,
the end up,
he's,
he's so doom and gloom,
you know,
I have some people that I know that I'm
friends with that are so,
so this is the end of the world.
Like you gotta look at it this way,
bureau,
the apocalypse is here but not here.
Okay.
It's on the earth in certain spots.
It always has been.
It's just back then when you described
the apocalypse and the plague.
Well yeah,
there was a plague in northern Africa,
but guess where there wasn't a plague in
fucking China at the same time in China.
They were challenged.
They were banging,
make more Chinese people.
They were,
you know,
they were playing fucking games.
It's you have access right now to too
much information for our puny brains and
that's where religion and any sort of a
predetermined pattern of behavior that
you can follow as an operating system,
whether it's been an amish person or
anything.
That's why they come in handy because
things so squirrely,
things are so crazy.
You look the fucking,
the meltdown in Japan and fucking
Mississippi's underwater and you the
fucking tornadoes go through Alabama and
birds are falling from the sky.
It never ends either way.
Looking at the view,
looking for shitty things.
You can find them all day and I'll tell
you something.
If for any of the young people that are
listening,
if you think it's worse today,
pick up any piece of literature or
history.
Just take a look like.
Take a look at Lincoln's life and you'll
find that back.
Then let's just take Lincoln's.
Okay?
Civil
war,
first of all,
you always last two or three or your
children to all kinds of diseases.
For example,
diptheria t,
when was the last time?
Who Do you know who ever died of
whooping cough,
diphtheria,
tetanus,
smallpox.
These diseases would roll through and
epidemics and it wasn't like the flu or
a cold.
You died slowly and horrible and it was
usually your child under a tent that you
couldn't touch,
so if anybody tuberculosis,
tuberculosis,
when you got consumption,
which is another word for tuberculosis,
and it's just anytime you read any kind
of any piece of literature history from
even 50 years ago,
it is always is always a story about
somebody.
Eugene O'Neill,
Nobel prize winning playwright,
his brother got tuberculosis and he had
to watch him die and long day's journey
into night is about that.
There was nothing you could do,
man.
You know what they do?
Go Up to the mountains and breathed the
air to see if it helps your lungs.
Otherwise you fucking died and that was
one disease of of cow.
Look at polio.
Sixty years ago,
50 years ago when kids were on iron
lungs and the best case scenario,
you're child is four.
He'll never walk again.
That was the best case scenario,
but usually you just died because your
lungs didn't hold up and we've invented
that.
That's,
that's the fundamental difference.
Nobody that's listening right now,
I guarantee knows anybody who has even
been crippled by something like polio
scarred by something like smallpox,
so the world in a lot of ways we're
feeding in the seventies,
in the seventies and in especially in
the sixties,
China and India.
Half the world's population was
starving,
man.
They couldn't even.
They,
they had to import grain now in the as a
huge grain exporter.
So because of the green revolution,
because of what's that guy's name,
one man who came up with ways to make,
you know,
to grains and things more and more
resistant to drought and things like
that are our advancements.
Our technological advancements have
pushed us so far beyond our biology.
It's not even funny.
However,
you're right,
it's so overwhelming and moving so
quickly that people feel like they,
since they can't understand it,
they have to come up with some kind of
a,
a debunking mechanism or something they
can understand or at least something
they can hold onto and that's where
religion plays a huge part.
I don't think religion,
I don't think technology is,
is pushing religion out of the way.
In some ways.
I think this huge,
this huge,
um,
a multiple,
the exponential growth of technology is
actually ushering in a,
another wave and that is a wave of very
religious people who have,
who don't know how to put this
technology,
technological wave into context,
tissue regeneration,
all the stuff we talk about.
It's also that you were able to contact
many people in our groups and get very
selective on the internet too.
You can choose just to hang out in one
or two sort of forums and you can just
think the way they think.
Nick,
Nick Swardson does such a funny joke
about that.
He ever sees joke about his new job.
He's like,
you know,
back before the Internet,
if you had a fetish man,
it was just really hard to find like,
you know,
a group or just anybody you could get
hit with you.
You'd have to go out to dinner and be
like,
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna.
Go to the bathroom unless you want me to
piss on your face.
I'm just kidding.
That's hilarious.
Because it's true.
Feel it out and shit.
There's so many weird groups that we're
finding out about from doing this
podcast and you have to talk to porn
stars.
You have to.
They hold you down and sometimes you
know,
you,
you get into conversations like you
know,
like you find out things like cream pies
and you know,
and foot jobs and all these different,
like really creepy things that are just
totally standard.
Their standard.
It's used to be fine.
When I was 14 years old,
we always used to find porn in the woods
and everyone shares this story is,
by the way,
all over the country.
I grew up in Boston.
I've talked to friends that grew up in
La.
I've talked to front.
You found porn in the woods.
We all used to find magazines in the
woods and I remember,
I will remember this.
This is the very day that the darkness,
the dark side of sexuality was revealed
to me because normally when you find
these magazines,
you'd find like Time magazine,
you know,
and then there would be like a playboy
inside of it.
Someone who would be naughty,
you know what I mean?
Like if you would find what over
someone's house,
but if you find them in the woods,
you know,
like I never bought a magazine until I
was like 20.
You always found them over someone's
house or you stole it from Your Dad's
bathroom or something.
But the magazines that you would get
from your dad,
but like penthouse if you're lucky.
Right.
They go gynecological more.
They show the pussy spot.
But when I was in the woods,
you'd find like Hustler and Sherry and
yes,
screw and it,
I,
I stumbled upon this one magazine.
It was me and my friends,
and I'll never forget this
because my friend Juan,
my friend Juan Alvarado,
he,
uh,
he was the first one to talk and we were
all sitting around looking at this
magazine and we peel through it page by
page for like five minutes,
just page.
And he finally goes,
dude,
I think this magazines all dicks and
feet.
It was the whole magazine was Dixon
And I remember this because also it was
the first time my friend,
my friend Josh,
who,
uh,
who was the next one to speak.
It was the first time I ever heard
someone say,
what the fuck in a way that I knew they
didn't really want him to answer.
You know,
when you say what the fuck?
Occasionally say,
what the fuck are you come home,
there's water everywhere.
What the fuck?
But sometimes you'll say,
what the fuck?
Where it's like,
Fuck,
you don't really want an answer man.
There's no way you can have an answer.
There's certain times when you say,
what the fuck?
Where if you were expecting to answer,
you asked the wrong question and this is
one of them,
this,
this fucking magazine,
this magazine that we found under a log,
right?
It's always there,
always damp.
The pages are stuck together and it was
all dicks and feet.
It was so weird.
It was all white guys.
You can never find a black dick if you
were looking for some black dick back in
the day.
It was very difficult.
I didn't see a black Dick until the
internet came along and then I was like,
wow,
they really are bigger back then man.
You never saw a black dick.
That shit was a room or,
or you wrestled and you saw in the
locker room,
you know,
you know every now and then you'd be
like,
God damn,
fuck is that,
but back done porn.
Now point every girl,
you're not worth your salt unless you
get fucking gang banged by.
A couple of black guys that said
separates the girls from the women that
separates the pros,
that separates the real slots,
the real girls who go in there and
there's three fucking giant juiced up
football player,
black dudes with logs and their parents
and they're going to fuck every hole and
you're going to pretend you love it or
do love it.
Either way.
Love it.
Go for it from my masturbation material.
Yeah Bro.
You feel bad and get,
get off at this stop.
Sluts.
Just got to be nice to them.
And you know,
I think slots are just like every other
component and the society inevitable,
you know,
and,
and porn stars and Comedians and
everything.
There's,
it's almost like this society has a
piece in place to counteract every other
piece that moves along with it.
In this society comes if you're hot
enough,
comes with a certain amount of power and
cache.
And by the way,
salary,
uh,
you know,
and hate and forget about that.
What about the hate you get from the
other women that you know you're,
you're not playing by their rules
on the first day.
What it is is they're just tapping into
our base evolutionary that the chimp
side.
If the chimpanzee and you know you.
Yeah,
it's just total genetic thing.
We don't want to be around that girl
because you know there's a place for
that.
I mean,
it's,
there.
I,
I often think that it's there the same
rate for the same reason,
religions,
they're all this controlling behaviors
because we ultimately have this weird
sort of a group goal and the weird group
goal is the progression of technology.
The weird group goal is burger and I say
that and people say,
well,
no,
it's not just about technology.
It's about social engineering.
It's about lifetime.
Yeah,
but what's at the front of the front of
the line?
The front of the line is what's the
latest,
greatest shit we're inventing?
How much does the culture evolve?
We still have most of the same fucking
stupid laws in place that were in place
in the sixties and seventies.
Pot is still illegal.
Okay.
Could the culture is still walked out of
their mind,
you know,
the culture still really fucking weird,
but technology is in another place.
The evolution of technology is a
thousand times faster.
Well,
you know what it does.
Technology,
for example,
in porn for example,
it gives you exactly what you want right
now in every technicolor detailed,
and there was an article I read by this,
I can't remember her name.
Is this a slutty mix?
Fuck stick.
Who said that?
They're.
They're finding this interesting
phenomenon with teenage boys and that is
that these kids are now have access to
red tube.
They're watching porn starting at 10,
nine and they're getting exactly what
they want.
Here's the problem.
When you and I,
when you and I saw a naked girl that
right when we met,
we didn't have the Internet right?
When you saw and you saw that,
you were just like,
oh shit.
I wasn't worried about life.
I wasn't worried about shaving.
I was just like,
just the smell of think.
She could have a whole funnel horn.
I'm fucking her.
I don't care.
I'm,
I'm this far.
Now what they're finding is boys are,
they're so used to seeing perfection and
exactly what they want,
that they'll see a girl and they'll be
like,
ah,
she's got a dent there.
I don't like that.
Fuck it.
I'm poured onto the next and these kids
are going from girl to girl to girl to
girl and girls are having a rise to that
occasion and become sluttier and
sluttier to keep to hold a boys'
interest and they've done a lot of early
instincts,
social studies on it,
which you know,
what is causing.
It's causing boredom.
It's causing sexual boredom among the
what?
Their articles a week.
Well,
yeah,
I mean or or anybody else is getting
more butts or addictions or we are,
we're in sexual sexuality can very well
be in anything where you think about it
too much can be in a desert chasing a
sensation.
Yeah.
Whether it's good or bad,
you know,
look,
I've been addicted to a lot of fucking
things in my life.
I've never been addicted to a drug,
but I've been addicted to a lot of
fucking things in my life.
And there was a guy,
there was one of the clearest forms of
sexual addiction.
There was this guy that was in a
wheelchair and he was a nice guy and he
used to play in this pool league that I
played in.
We played this,
um,
there's a weekly tournament and he was
always there and he had to play in a
wheelchair and he was in the fucking
hard man.
It's hard going around in life.
We can't move your legs.
So you started talking to me about
prostitutes,
that he gets a lot of prostitutes.
I'm like,
all right.
Yeah,
good.
This guy gets some prostitutes probably,
you know,
guys got a lot of fucking pent up sexual
pressure and I hope they don't take
advantage of them.
Right?
Then he starts talking about how he gets
really upset if their feet aren't
perfect.
He got like really weird and I'm like,
well,
well here's a guy who's an ugly guy.
He's ugly and he's talking about girls
and wasn't just talking about
prostitutes.
He but he doesn't like their feet.
Their feet have to be perfect.
They have to be perfect.
She is not taking care of her feet.
I get upset and I'm like,
God damn did.
You should be so happy that someone
wants a hug.
Do you give a fuck what color her nails
are on our toes?
Weirdo.
You know,
according
to this one book called the murder room
that,
that this guy who was a serial killer
profile of specializes in sadism and he,
he,
he's,
you know about this.
It's really interesting.
The society where they,
they get together.
I'm like the third Thursday of every
month,
all these retired profilers and
detectives and they solve cold cases and
the rule is it's got to be an ingest
case where a little girl was killed or
something like that.
It can't be a drug dealer was knocked
off they find,
but it's usually the deal with serial
killers and people got away with it and
they think it's as serial killer and
they've solved a lot of crimes and he
said,
and he's,
he's the.
He basically wrote the helix on,
on the evolution of a serial killer that
the FBI still uses today.
I'm profiling and he said that almost
all serial killers start with a fetish
fetish and,
and once you get into the fetish,
once you get into,
you know,
whatever it might be,
coming on somebody's feet and then you
want to then you want to,
you know,
maybe choke them or whatever.
You don't go back.
You mentally never go back to being
normal.
Once you start going down the rabbit
hole,
some people stopped,
some people will stop it,
you know,
they like to stop at whatever it might
be shitting on your fucking.
This is extreme fetishes.
This is not just like I have a fetish
for Asians,
know a lot of them will start rubbing
against strangers in buses that's
foreign trained,
so they'll take trains and they and
they'll just rub up against a stranger.
Here's another really creepy one.
Sometimes they'll find leather coach
cut,
like just really cut with a razor.
That's something called peaker rhythm,
which is where they like to cut your
skin.
That shit is a very common thing.
That's where it's fucking,
so they're cutting you like when you're
standing in an elevator or something,
the size about it,
you know,
and they practice on coats,
but they'll do it in a public place
because it's dangerous.
It's like,
you know,
they might get caught fucking nutty shit
man.
It's more weird shit where the fucking
mind is not wired,
right?
That is that.
Is that a social thing?
There's a,
there's,
there's a lot,
there's a lot of new science to suggest
that if you are an evil person,
let's say you're a serial killer or are
you just a killer?
What,
what?
There's a lot of evidence to suggest
that you lack the ability not only with
the [inaudible],
which is the part of the brain that I
guess,
you know,
deals with compassion and things,
but you also may also not have the
neuron synapses required to actually
fire when somebody is being hurt and it
causes a sense of a distain or,
or,
um,
or you feel bad about it.
So.
So as we learn more about the brain,
it may just be that criminals,
for the most part,
our brain damaged are simply brain
damage.
So that raises a really important
question if then you can prove that
someone has a lesion the size of a
pinhead on a certain part of their brain
that causes them to lack any kind of
compassion and in fact caused him not to
be able to feel at all.
And so they have to do crazy shit just
to feel just to be alive.
Right?
So what do you do with that person?
What does that.
What does that say?
Well,
you can kill them.
You can kill them.
But I'm talking about as a society,
if you see that they are brain damaged,
now here's another study them and kill
them.
Okay?
Or how about this?
What if you have the means to actually
fix that lesion on the brain?
Depends on what they've done it.
They've already done something fucked
up.
You got to kill him.
What if I could prove scientifically
that they're all hundred percent normal
with all the ability to feel
compassionate?
You still got.
It's still jealous,
right?
To kill him.
You can't have them walking around with
that guy killed your sister.
Do you imagine if you were walking
around and some guy killed your sister
is like,
hey,
sorry you just said some shit wrong with
my brain,
but it does raise.
It does raise questions.
We're going to be grappling with that.
Another thing about technology as we
learn more about the brain and you find
that a lot of criminals have an
underdeveloped,
for example,
meticulous.
I think that's the word.
Is that what the part of the bedroom?
No,
let's say,
but medically because it's make up
another word.
Sounds.
Look it up on the Internet like a
regular.
But the point is that,
that's fucking interesting to me.
What was your actual brain damaged?
So you don't have the ability to feel.
You don't even fucking know how to
process that and you haven't since you
were born isn't.
But where does that come from?
Because a huge percentage of the serial
killers that seemed to come from some
sort of a torture is childhood.
Uh,
yes.
But is that some don't bullshit.
Maybe because Jeffrey Dahmer's parents
claimed that they didn't fuck him,
you know,
everything is fine.
He's pretty normal.
The Yo Yo,
something happened.
There is no,
I don't buy that.
There's no question though,
that a lot of very evil people let's
take stolen and not actually not a good
example.
Well,
let's take.
There are a lot of like,
like shitty the really terrible
dictators,
right?
But isn't it a part of the real problem
is finding the God who the fuck knows
when?
I think that you're definitely wounded
some time in your,
in a crucial stage of development.
Probably that seems to be at another
theory.
I've heard where people say as you're
developing,
a lot of times if you're developing
sexually and mentally at a certain age
and you see something really horrific
and violent,
you will,
you can associate violence with sexual,
um,
release.
There's all kinds of shit like that.
Or as a way of coping with something you
can't even put into context,
you'd turn it sexual because it's a
defensive mechanism.
A lot of girls that have been,
except that a lot of girls who've been
molested and raped,
they turn to porn.
That's exactly right,
because they.
We live the trauma,
they call it reliving it strange.
You would think that it would turn them
off.
Some people it does,
but what the.
The,
the mystery is that you see people who
go through the worst abuse in the world
and they come out of it incredible
people who give back to society and
there everybody's hero and then you see
somebody wear.
One thing happens,
one thing happens at the right time and
they turn into.
They're there.
They're in and out of Rehab for the rest
of their life.
Look at,
look at people who make a shitload of
money.
A lot of their kids good looking tall to
doing all the thing and they spend their
whole life battling a drug drug problem.
Whereas one dude comes up from in an
orphanage and ends up running the
fucking running a company or you know,
whatever it might be,
but you know,
I think it's all really kind of clear.
If you look at it like in the
progression of their lives and what kind
of experiences have they had,
how they move towards,
you know,
solving or getting past that experience
and what can you learn from watching
them.
I mean,
if you really wanted to really wanted to
take the crazy point of view,
the crazy point of view is that this
world is really your imagination and
that everything that takes place in this
world is really a lesson for you.
You can either learn from it or not.
You can see the whole thing is some
grand play played out for your amusement
and in every weakness you can,
you can,
you can learn.
And one of the issues that I have with
human beings and like I said with
religion,
I,
I get upset at things that I'm afraid of
seeing in myself.
You know,
I get upset at weakness in people.
I get upset at jealousy,
I get upset,
I get upset at all the things that I'm
terrified of seeing in myself.
And it's almost like that that plays out
for you.
It's like these are all,
here's your school.
The world is your,
your.
This is your path to enlightenment.
Here's the world in front of you.
This is a shaky roadmap of
enlightenment.
You said something that that always
stuck with me.
I never forgot it and I wasn't that
young guy when you said it.
It was actually kind of recent.
It was about five years ago and there
was this situation that I'd been at
dinner and I fucking freaked out and my
girlfriend time and you said to me the
next day you go,
dude,
you got to become the star of the movie
that you live in.
You can't be.
You can't behave that way because that's
not what the star of the movie would do.
In other words,
you.
You make a choice as to how you behave
and who you want to be,
and that is a series of choices that you
can choose to be someone that you would
admire.
That's
exactly fucking right and that's not
easy to do.
It takes responsibility.
It takes saying no to a lot of shit,
but it does,
but it's also.
It is a.
In a way it's also,
it is easier in a way,
make your fucking choice and I think you
also know exactly.
I always find people who act like
they're really confused and they'll ask
me advice about how to live their life
and I started looking at him like,
dude,
you know exactly what you're supposed
to.
Yes,
but no,
it is very confusing if you haven't made
steps already,
if you,
if you're one of those purposes,
people that have never ventured into the
deep water and you're free to jump in,
it's fucking scary.
The big for a lot of people,
any sort of changes,
terrifying,
any movement and we're,
you know,
I'm thinking about leaving this job and
pursuing my dreams.
That's fucking terrifying for a lot of
terrifying because a lot of times it
doesn't work out,
but I just,
but they haven't done it.
If you've done it a bunch of times,
like,
Hey,
I already did this already.
Did that already tried move on here.
And sports sports make a band up.
I mean I was listening to mark Marin,
I think he was talking to Greg
Fitzsimmons.
Somebody sent me this clip we're
married,
was talking about how if he was upset
with anything was that his parents never
instilled a sense of healthy competition
in him.
For him it was always,
if he's losing the game,
he's throwing the board up in the air
and then the fucking games over because
he left because he couldn't take it
because it was like life or death and
that's such an important point man.
And a healthy form of competition and by
healthy one of the things is you got to
lose.
I was about to say,
you got to feel that you learn a lot
more.
A lot of times by losing.
You learn what you're doing wrong.
You get motivated.
You know,
I,
I still to this day do a lot of Jujitsu
and one of the things about Jujitsu is
you get tapped,
man,
you get tapped all the time.
I roll with good guys so I get caught,
man.
It's just.
And when you're getting caught,
it's a matter of do I tap out or does my
arm break?
Do I tap out or are you going to fuck my
neck up?
You know,
and this is,
but by doing that all the time,
you get very humble and you get used to
losing and winning and you realize that
your,
the,
the good that you do,
whether you're good,
do good at Jujitsu or any other game.
One of the reasons why I'm obsessed with
games because there's a direct
correlation in my mind between focusing
excellence,
like focusing my energy and my
concentration on something and then
seeing direct results and then applying
those direct results to the rest of my
life and with some people they never
have any real competition in their life.
And because of that,
when anything comes up,
anything that's big,
anything that does require you to rise
to the occasion or,
or deal with a social issue,
you fucking lock up,
man.
He's out.
You freeze up because it's scary.
You know,
you,
you know Michael Jordan,
they always say he had his,
he hills.
These statistic for hitting the most of
last minute winning shots.
Okay.
Guess what?
He also holds this statistic for the
most losing,
missing the most game,
winning shots.
He's also a notorious gambling addicts,
but that's,
but that's in a book that's in a book
called the outliers and I thought was
really interesting.
Take some chance.
He.
He missed this many.
He missed more than he made.
Now he's a legend and he was the
greatest basketball player ever,
but that took a lot of fucking missing
and a lot of losing.
It took a lot of obsession to.
It's.
He's a fascinating subject to me.
I followed him very closely.
Yes,
very closely because I'm obsessed with
extreme winters.
I'm because I think there's a madness to
it and I truly believe that in order to
be truly great at something,
you have to give into a certain amount
of madness and how much can you manage
that madness?
I don't know,
but guess what?
If you want to be that guy flying
through the fucking air with your tongue
out in front of the baddest
motherfucking basketball players in the
world and kicking shit on the level that
they've never seen before.
Dr Jay,
suck my Dick.
Stupid.
Watch this.
I'm going to fly through the air.
How about that?
How about I'm going to do some shit that
nobody's ever done.
I'm going to hit some fucking layups
that's going to have all you white
bitches scratching your head already.
Line used to say,
if Michael Jordan had been on the
titanic,
it would not have sung.
It would have been fucking fucked.
Every.
Hi.
I am fascinated by ultra bad
motherfuckers,
but there's a reality to the.
There's a madness to them.
To all of them,
every single one of them.
And Michael Jordan is a extreme one last
at pool wants.
Didn't talk to his teammate for three
days.
Yeah,
I believe it.
I believe he's also got a real real
problem with gambling and any sort of
games and I know that that thing in
myself,
when I was younger I had a real problem
with it.
I'm much,
much better now,
but when I was younger I had a real
problem with games and he's got it bad
man with golf.
He's got a bad dude.
He loses and he doesn't even pay.
Gets mad at people and doesn't pay.
He owed some fucking golf hustler,
a half a million dollars and the guy
wrote a story.
It was,
I believe it was esquire.
It was esquire,
Gq,
one of those magazines and there was a
big story about Michael Jordan and you
know how he's.
How is gambling with Michael Jordan?
Michael Jordan wouldn't pay him and
Michael Jordan is just this ultra bad
motherfucker who's obsessed with it.
He just has to constantly get new pussy
has to constantly get the latest
Ferrari.
He has to constantly be playing golf and
winning money and gambling and
basketball games and gambling on
baseball games and gambling on whatever
the fuck he can.
Man.
He's just out there.
I think a lot of hype.
A lot of athletes have so much trouble.
Fucking how about this?
Go to [inaudible] dot com for 60
percent.
Sixty percent of NFL football players
leave the league and bankruptcy do.
Did you see that?
There was a thing about all the
different basketball players.
Check that out because I think I on
factcheck.com,
I believe that's the statistic.
60.
We can check it out right now.
Sixty percent of would you say UF NFL
football players are bankrupt?
I think it's like a year after they've,
they've,
they played football or by the time they
retire or something crazy,
but just see what norm mcdonald bed on
that pack fight the other day.
Oh,
well I know a guy who bet $800,000.
Are you serious?
How about that?
I know a guy who bet 800,000 to 100
class.
I'll have that fucking kind of.
I mean to win 100,000.
That was pretty safe,
but yet he didn't fight up to 60 percent
within five years of retirement.
Sixty percent of NFL football players
within five years of retirement are
bankrupt.
Think about that.
It's because you're just invincible.
You're the biggest,
strongest,
fastest guy in the world.
And you've gotta get that juice somehow
buy shit.
You got to just,
you know.
Well,
there was a,
there was a thing about pro athletes
that have all been,
uh,
that have lost all their money and their
guy.
So like Latrell sprewell guys who like
big names,
and they're broke.
They owe millions and millions of
dollars,
you know,
and I have this weird thing or going hip
hop sites and I look hip hop sites.
One of the things that you see nowadays
is how many guys are in bankruptcy?
Like a half of their gossip.
You know,
everyone's got their own gossip.
you go on like baby websites,
celebrity baby.
Oh,
you know,
it looks like they're fighting and you
know the baby's turned for you know,
but you go on hip hop websites and the
gossip is overwhelming.
This guy's losing his house.
Or you're a hip hop.
The first thing you should do in your
entourage,
just have fucking three accountants
everywhere.
Just just hire good in New York.
Find a Jewish or Italian accountant
happened.
Fucking follow you around all the time.
Well,
you know Iran Barkley,
you know who he was,
right?
Be Thomas hearns former thinks super
middleweight champion.
Bad,
bad by the bass,
but he turned homeless.
I became homeless.
He had a major crack problems.
Was it a crack problem?
Really?
I didn't know that,
but what they were saying,
what he was saying rather was he was
hanging out with Eddie Murphy and
Micheal or hanging out with Eddie
Murphy,
Arsenio Hall,
and he's like,
I had to fucking keep up,
you know,
so he was buying a Mercedes and the best
watches and then that shit runs dry and
you know that's like the most transient
of jobs or the most temporary jobs by
the way.
How much,
how much money do you would know?
Better than I would if you make.
If you got a $20 million dollar payday
right in here.
How much of that money after taxes and
and Jews?
A lot.
How much do you?
There's a lot that's missing.
Okay.
The God who was the guy that's making
the $20,000,000.
Thanks.
I have $20,000,000.
But you don't.
You've got to.
First of all,
yeah,
you got about six.
Maybe you might not even have six.
You might have for because you have to
pay taxes.
Okay.
So half is gone when you're in.
When you're above $200,
$250,000.
Is it or is it $400,000?
Whatever the fuck it is,
there's a certain level to your above
where you're essentially paying 40
something percent in taxes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So there's,
there's that.
Then you have managers and agents,
so I don't know how it is in,
in boxing,
but in a,
in a lot of,
uh,
in,
in comedy for instance,
you and I,
we have a manager and an agent.
The manager takes 15 percent.
The agent takes 10.
There's 25 of business management.
Yes.
So there's 30.
So money's gone for getting a publicist
to have one,
but of course you have property taxes
and there's a lot of things you have to
pay.
The bills are high,
but the amount of money that you
actually get is like thirty four cents
on a dollar or something silly like
that.
Something ridiculous.
Yeah.
So yeah,
so these guys spend like they actually
have 20 million bucks,
but that's part of the fun man.
It's part of the fun is watching someone
walking around with giant diamond
encrusted chains and crazy fucking
watches.
And then a month later,
finding out that they lost their or
something.
There's something she'll rub where you
put your own amusement,
go rogue and do a comic who had a huge
deal.
He bought a Rolls Royce six months later
he was living in it.
So who was that?
I,
I don't know.
That's out there enough.
Notice.
I can't remember the guys.
Was that I'm a Ford Edge.
So Ford makes a solid fucking.
Christ was making a big comeback because
of a,
uh,
an m and m commercial.
Then eminem commercial about Detroit.
Some slick Detroit commercial that they
did for the superbowl.
Right?
I drive a Prius and even my fucking
listen brother the only live this one
life to get yourself an MP.
Three.
You got some money?
Yeah.
I used to have a BMW,
right?
Get in my car for a couple of days.
Greater Trevor.
Running them three.
Get some.
You got some money,
man.
I'm not saying you should just blow it
and get crazy,
but enjoy it.
Don't drive a fucking Prius.
You're in the hangover.
Tucson fucking solid car by the way.
I'll be at the Edmonton comic strip on
Wednesday,
Wednesday to fucking Sunday.
I will be bringing the heat.
Edmonton,
Alberta,
Canada.
Shit,
fun fucking place.
They have a lot of fights up there.
They have the MFC.
They put,
they put on big fights up there and a
couple of times I've done comedy shows
like right before the flight and the
fucking crowds are great love Canadians.
They get the comedy that go with you and
they're polite and they're just fucking.
They're so awesome.
Then they have a good sense of humor.
How was it?
How was the air quality when you were
filming the hangover too?
It's super bad.
Their right place smells.
I'm not.
I don't mean Thailand.
People at beautiful,
wonderful people,
but Bangkok and Tom's been Bangkok just
by the nature of the city and there's a.
It smells like garlic soup.
It smells like I was on the top of my
hotel and I was like that.
It does well.
Bangkok smells a lot,
a lot like fish and garlic and soup.
If you mix that together,
it.
That's not far right.
They're great people.
The ties are fucking awesome.
How long were you there for the only
country never been colonized,
by the way.
At oil?
Yeah.
Thailand is the only country where you
could make the argument for Vietnam,
but they'd gone through so many wars
fighting for their independence,
their bad has people,
but the ties somehow we're always able
to compromise and find a way to be just
in the middle.
Think about Indochina in that area and
how fucking incredibly volatile that
always been.
The Chinese were always invading
Vietnam.
They were already knew.
That whole part was just.
Light was always hard.
Vietnamese are tough fucking people
because their history has been a
thousand years of keeping people out of
their fucking country.
The French,
the Chinese,
the Americans,
they just never gave up.
When you look at fucking ties,
somehow somehow they were able to just
keep everything real kosher.
They just played the road.
They were like,
Hey,
America will your friends,
but not really good friends.
Hey Roger,
you guys want to fuck our girl?
We got great food,
beautiful women.
The weather's great commodity to wild
culture.
Thai fights,
their fights in Thailand really are like
those old van Damme movies.
They're waving cash in the area in
gambling tough.
They're no joke,
but they're just.
They're really good at being communal
like that.
I think.
I think at the root of Thai culture is
this notion of being able to compromise
and negotiate and not,
not spoiling,
not taking the fucking chessboard thrown
in the air.
Just let's just,
let's keep playing.
I lost a little bit,
but it's not just a battle in the war
itself is a,
there is no or it's a beautiful way of
looking at life.
They're not too competitive about shit.
They have a king still right and you
can't shit on the king.
Well,
Thailand is an incredibly liberal place
for and,
and I did a little reading on the
culture and seven,
eight,
a very liberal place.
But the one thing that they never,
they have no sense of humor about as
their king nailing it.
And the reason is because there's a,
there's a,
there's a form of superstition.
It's what a lot of people,
uh,
they're very superstitious about their
king.
There king is considered to be a semi
deity and they take that shit seriously
and I was there,
um,
I don't know what the holiday was,
but it was a time when you were supposed
to give alms to the king and,
and it was a religious ceremony and they
would walk by and all of them would put
their hands together.
Even people on the street would walk by
the Golden Shrine and put their hands
together and bow.
So it might be one of the last cultures
on earth and that feels that way about
their king.
I mean,
you know,
like North Korea,
North Korea is under a dictatorship is
terrible.
The Tibetans have this notion that the,
that the Dalai Lama is the.
Because that's a religious thing,
but this is also a little bit as well I
think so very much do.
Wow.
Does the King Do Shady Shit?
No other king.
From what I understand,
his son is a little bit different than
sun is falling a little bit out of favor
with the people.
He's a playboy and a product of just,
you know,
how shit,
but his dad,
his dad is.
And,
and by the way,
I mean son was,
you don't hear bad things about his son,
but his father was always this sort of
sober stayed presence is just having a
good time.
He really,
he took it.
Yeah.
But,
but even that kid,
they take their,
their role as a symbol very,
very seriously.
And they know how important and how,
uh,
how important assemble they are.
Um,
to sort of uh,
uh,
you know,
the,
the notion that we are,
we are what you should aspire to it,
which is,
you know,
being conservative like a lot of things
about the Thai women,
like people think well because there are
a lot of like strip clubs and there's a
big sex trade.
They're,
that Thai women are losing.
Absolutely not.
In fact,
in Thai culture,
women aren't,
they?
They're,
it's not like you just go fuck a lot of
people at all.
They're very conservative in their own
families.
And as,
as a,
as a group of people.
I've talked to a lot of Thai people
about that and,
and women who were there who were
working in some,
she was like,
it's a huge misconception,
the notion that you can just meet a Thai
girl and get been,
haven't been banked.
So it's just the prostitutes are just so
prevalent because they make it legal,
don't try to control it.
They and they zone it.
There's a,
there's a red light district where I
spent all my time and,
and,
and they have numbers and it's,
and you know,
you can get it for $19.
You can,
you can pay the bar,
find wherever the fuck it is,
60 bucks,
you can bring them back.
It's all very cheap.
But you see these disgusting fat
barnacle written German tourists who are
60 with this like,
you know,
15 year old farm girl from the north of
Thailand or Cambodia or good.
And uh,
and it's not a,
it's not a,
a sinful thing.
And their culture.
Now it's almost like I'm,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna help this person.
Uh,
it's like I'm going to give them a
massage.
And so either way,
I think a huge strength of the
Thai people also is the notion that
there's a lot of power and strength in
given there's a lot of power and
strength and being subservient and
making you feel welcome and have a good
time.
Dude,
I'm fucking moving to Thailand.
I'll tell you something.
If I was an old single dude who just
liked to watch kickboxing,
I fucking move to Thailand if I didn't
have any friends.
I heard the air quality is so bad.
They can't walk around with a mask.
But you don't have to live in Bangkok.
No,
you live in Bali is paquette.
Cool.
As I thought about going their vacation,
I'd never been.
Who's Tiger Moitai there.
I'm like,
how cool would it be to go on vacation?
Just trained more for.
It's beautiful.
Hanging out.
Probably some of the best scuba diving
in the world.
Is it safe for tourists and everything?
That's the other thing about even
Bangkok,
incredibly safe.
Even Bangkok,
Bangkok,
you know,
I mean,
it's a huge city.
I never once heard anybody telling me
you shouldn't walk around.
I walked around everywhere you go
everywhere,
you know all the Zack,
Zack Alford,
clearly had never seen mad TV.
That's exactly.
I got recognized.
I had my feet massaged.
That's it.
Then I got jerked.
No girls for Dixon Dixon feet.
It just brought it back.
See if anybody want to coconut water.
Yeah.
Thank you too for sending me some case
with.
Appreciate you.
Lucky.
I love coconut water to girls for
Thailand.
You went silent just to see.
So he stopped talking.
He saw the coconut water.
You stopped talking
water.
What was uh,
what was the nature of your stay?
You were filming the hangover two.
And for how long were you there?
I was there for almost two weeks.
I stayed at the four seasons sun suite,
like a player when you do it by
yourself,
you didn't fly family now.
I was just by myself.
Two weeks.
Man.
That's a long time to freak out now when
I'm away.
But um,
I don't really like traveling.
I did so much of it as a kid that I
just,
you know,
I've had an opportunity to go to South
Africa.
And when you lived in the Middle East,
this is something I wanted to talk to
you about because I wanted to know if
you remember the place that you were
when you heard the news that the prince
was with
Prince Prince was what?
I just said that because that was
probably the highlight of my life and I
was sleeping.
I'm kidding.
I wasn't.
Of course,
this woman said to me two in the
morning,
this woman said to me like,
I bet you didn't leave and watch.
You didn't even watch the thing.
Just like I go,
no,
I did.
I didn't.
I didn't want some straight.
And I'm a man.
I said this woman actually it was.
My mom was trying to figure out who said
it to me.
Because you ever.
You never know how someone says
something,
you need to go.
Who the fuck said that?
Because it was like,
in my mind I was like,
this older woman.
Why am I talking to her?
She's had a store.
Oh,
it's my mom.
My mom was just here.
Sorry.
We have to be the prince.
I,
I'll tell you,
if I was a prince that was a good
looking guy like he was,
I wouldn't begin logging married.
Yeah.
He's got to be a fucking dirty bastard.
He's got to do what he's got to do
though.
You don't.
But anyway,
my mom said you didn't watch it,
did you?
I go,
no,
and she goes,
well,
there's these gay folks that lived down
the street from us.
They had a big party.
They had a big party for the prints.
I go,
really?
How awesome is that?
She goes,
it was hilarious.
they were talking about her dress and
her shoes and they all got excited.
They had like 50 people over their house
watching the wedding on TV.
They got up early because it's alive,
you know,
it's different times so crazy,
like 10 hours ahead of us or something,
at least eight hours ahead of us.
He'd been following all this Osama shit.
Like,
oh,
that's as.
He grew weed on his,
on his arm and he did grow weed,
but that's super common in the Middle
East.
Did you see the video that they released
yesterday?
I think that they released all these
like home videos that they found at that
compound.
They're suspect because you know,
the CIA's admitted that they were going
to make fake news stories.
Okay,
this is this fake at all.
but hold on a second.
You see the CIA has admitted in several
times that they were going to make fake
news stories.
This was after nine slash 11 and they
said to throw off the terrorists,
they were going to make fake news
stories.
As soon as they start saying that,
letting everybody know we're going to
lie to you,
that the depths of their lives is only
in your imagination.
Who the fuck knows?
I mean when when you see him and he's
got like his beard is dyed black and
then you see other videos of him and his
beard is white.
I don't buy that,
but hold on this.
This is why I don't buy that is because
they're right now will absolutely be an
active campaign to discredit him if they
have murdered him.
If they did shoot Osama bin Ladin,
any was unarmed,
they will discredit him and one of the
ways they're going to discredit him to
make him look vein and to make him look
like he's a,
a crazy dictator who's,
you know,
living in squalor,
like he's an insane person.
So if you show pictures of his house and
his house was all fucked up in disarray
and there's blood all over the place and
there's just garbage everywhere and then
you saw pictures of his beard and it's
black.
He looks like a nutty man.
You see the video of him and they're
just watching TV though.
How do you know that
he's got a white beard and that,
but it talks about conspiracy and the
idea that this might be a fake story.
They did take a look at how the US
government works.
Take a look at,
for example,
how these operations work.
Let me tell you something.
When you do a.
When you do a major operation like that,
you've got seal team six.
First of all,
it's got to go through all kinds of
civilian channels right away and they
have to be privy to all kinds of
information,
not dimension the Security Council and
everything else.
If you take a look at,
and I'm talking about the hundred people
at least to have top secret clearance
who all have different agendas and have
no interest in glorifying Barack Obama
at all,
and a lot of those people,
all of them.
I mean the idea that you could ever pull
off this,
this,
this fake assassination of Osama bin
Ladin after we've been trying to get him
for this long is is it wouldn't work.
Even in a Hollywood movie and when you
talk about fake stories,
what the CIA was doing with those fake
stories was they were leaking.
Then it's true two,
two,
two on Al Jazeera and things like that.
But mainly what they would do is they
want to get information out of you and
you're a young man who believes in you
are a mom and you got.
You got captured and they'll show you a
fake headline of the New York Times and
they'll say,
look,
what happened?
All your guys had been killed and all of
them are singing like canaries.
They used all kinds of technical course.
There's no doubt you don't want to trust
the CIA,
but the what's wonderful about
government,
and
this is just a fact,
is anytime you try to keep a secret or
come up with a huge conspiracy like
this,
you're dealing with 16 other people who
have a totally different agenda.
Who would want nothing more than to
expose you,
and anytime you have a group of people,
whether it's Kissinger and Nixon or
whoever who tried to come up with their
own agenda to steer foreign policy or my
God,
come up with a way to glorify their
president,
which is what this did for the
Democrats.
And I'll tell you something.
The Republicans are going to have no
they.
They can no longer use the notion that
Obama is weak on terrorism for this
upcoming election.
So I can promise you there were plenty
of Republicans who would have loved to
have taken credit for this.
You,
you,
you'd have to go through.
It'd be basically impossible.
I mean you can.
And by the way,
launching a team like seal team six,
that was so.
What was interesting about this was it
was so risky for the president that,
that notion.
Here's why.
If you're,
if you're young and you don't vote,
this is why.
Forget the platform you're on,
whether you're Republican or Democrat,
when you vote for a president,
make sure that guy has wisdom.
Make sure that guy is an intellect and
he has wisdom.
And here's why.
When you're the president of United
States,
you have very little power,
but you also have a great deal of power
and this is how it works.
They come to you with six different
scenarios and they say,
Mr. President,
we have a lot of intelligence to suggest
that Osam Osama bin Ladin,
who's been protected by the Isi and
whoever it is in Pakistan,
he is living in a compound now we could
drop.
Here's one of the options,
we could drop 60,000 pounds worth of
bombs on that and create a crater and
calm the place for DNA and see if it
really was him.
Or we can send in a crack commando team
like seal team six and take this guy
out.
Why is that risky?
Well,
here's why.
Couple reasons.
You're sending in a team,
it is a third of a mile or something
crazy or three miles less away from a
what,
what?
What Pakistan's west point is this huge
military facility.
They're gonna scramble jets,
which they did,
and a whole bunch of other things.
The minute they start hearing gunshots,
right?
Right.
In their quarter,
and by the way,
there are a lot of people in the
military probably know he's already
there anyway,
so we send on our team.
If Americans die and we fail at this or
RC helicopter stalls,
which it did.
You were taking,
you can say goodbye to your fucking your
election.
So you add all those guys in that war
room.
Hillary Clinton and Gates Hillary.
I said the news headline,
she was photo shopped out of the
picture.
There's photoshop,
a couple of countries,
photoshop,
that's funny because she's a woman,
but,
but the bottom line is you see all these
people including Obama sitting there
with incredible 10 incredibly tense
faces and he took the weekend to think
about whether or not to move in on that
and that's where the response.
So you think that the president really
gets that kind of a control.
I know he does know.
How do you know?
Because because because I read American
isn't a hangover to any biography from a
precedent.
You think that you really think that
there's one guy that gets to make the
call,
that that is how our government works.
The final,
the commander in chief makes the final
decision when you give them four or
five,
six sessions,
and by the way,
those scenarios come from the
department.
Defense Pentagon,
State Department.
They come your secretary of state,
they come from your soul.
Literally.
There is no military industrial complex
is one guy that's got his finger at the
button.
He's able to push all the switch.
That's not what I said.
What I said is that he gets to make the
call.
Military Industrial Complex is so many
competing interests as well,
but,
but it is true that there's a lot of
profit and war,
but there's also a lot of risks and I
agree with everything you've said.
I agree with everything you said about
the,
the seal team six,
the baddest motherfuckers in the world.
These are the guys that,
by the way,
if you don't know as being a seal is
incredibly difficult and they take the
best of the seals and 50 fucking percent
of them wash out because they can't
handle what it takes to be in seal team
six.
I mean,
I've read the Deq Marchenko books and
all the dude,
they're on another level of human bear.
They're on another level of human being
boss route and was telling me how he
trains the seal team six and there's a
record they had for running up and down
this hill.
Marc Hamann Acada.
He ran up and down this hill four times
is a huge hill.
The seal teams guys,
they did it 12 times and boss had to
stop them because he thought they were
going to die.
There are,
they're on another level.
There's another level and yeah,
and they're not going to do.
They all have different agendas,
but the bottom line is the government is
lying about a bunch of stories like this
in the past.
Jessica Lynch is a,
is a perfect example.
There's a woman that she was inside of a
fucking hospital and they pretend that
there was this crazy gun fight to get
her out and rescue her from the Iraqis
and what would really turn down was it
was just a girl in the hospital and
there was no bullets shot at all.
To your point and exactly what you just
said,
let me do.
Let me piggyback on that.
Exactly.
Now it would have been in our interest,
would have been very much in our
interest to say about Osama bin Laden.
They had a machine gun on a shooting at
us and you know what happened within.
Within hours as the stories started
unfolding,
the truth came out.
You know what?
That was a woman was in front of him.
She charged the guy shot her in the leg
and Obama,
Osama was not armed yet.
The guy shot him in the head right now.
Let me tell you,
that's been a question.
And,
and Banksy Moon,
I think of,
uh,
the secretary general of United States,
United Nations came out and said,
well,
you know,
there was no trial.
It's a bit barbaric.
I don't know if that was who said it,
but there was a lot of backlash and said
the guy was,
the guy was on,
on,
why the fuck didn't you arrest them
instead of shooting?
And by the way,
when they shot him,
they had a picture and the picture had.
The reason they haven't released it is
because part of his skull got blown
away.
Now what they do,
which is really just photoshop that a
blur that out,
here's a kit and a bride style.
Here's what they did.
Here's what they did when the seal teams
to.
How about this guy?
He shoots Osama bin Ladin in the head.
He takes a picture of it,
he fax it,
he scans and sends that to,
to,
to the office where they're all,
they're,
all these people are there.
They get this picture of a but in mom's
face.
How do you know what it is?
They put it through a facial recognition
scan right away,
which is about,
uh,
about as they take the geometric
portions where your nose,
your eyes.
It's just,
it's like a fingerprint.
And they go,
guess what?
That's a match.
That's the Sullivan Law.
Then they take DNA as well.
Then they got the body and you,
not many people saw his body probably
literally 100.
All the seal team guys,
all those people on that ship that dress
the body that read the rights and then
dumped at sea,
which
according to Islamic law,
you've got to bury a body 24 hours after
it's been killed.
But that's supposed to be at sea.
Well,
the reason I'm standing is a great
point.
And the reason they didn't,
they did it at sea because no country,
including Saudi Arabia where he's from.
We would take that body right?
Because then it would be a shrine to be
a shrine,
and Doug Stanhope had a great point.
You said,
how come these,
uh,
they identified his body within an hour
you had to take these poor fucking guys
that are wrongly accused.
Thirty years to get a DNA match to get
out of prison.
That's so true.
Dog Stand.
That was amazing.
It's so true.
This is a perfect point.
I mean the fuck man.
Is it?
Is it really that important to kill some
guy living in squalor?
I mean,
is it that much more important than
rescuing citizens that are wrongly
accused?
It's,
it's a good question too,
because it also raises this
assassination,
raises a fuck load of questions.
One of which is now that we've gotten
the big,
the big net name.
Do you have a justification for being in
Afghanistan?
No,
you don't.
I never did.
In the first place.
Listening to me,
they were in Afghanistan for minerals
and probably heroin over Afghanistan for
the Taliban had dropped heroin
production down to minuscule levels.
Now the United States is over there and
we produce shit more than 90 percent of
the world's heroin in Afghanistan.
More than 90 percent of the world's.
Everyone's grown up.
That's,
that's the world is big.
The world is big as fuck,
and if 90 percent of the Viagra was
grown in one little village,
guess what?
We would infiltrate that culture.
We would find a way to corrupt them and
turn them into terrorism.
We would have them attack ships or blow
things up and then we'd use that as an
excuse to go in and Jack.
They're Viagra.
That's what we would do because that's
what we've done forever.
This is what we do.
If there was a Viagra was luck,
dude,
big d hard dick pills are very fucking
valuable,
right?
If you didn't,
if they didn't exist,
I like tigers and get them in
Afghanistan,
in Afghanistan.
The number one way that they bribe
warlords,
because if you don't know the way I've
Ganesan is structured today in 2011,
the reason why it's an unwinnable
country and an unwinnable war because
it's not a country,
it's a series of war lords that are all
kind of interconnected and they all live
in these villages.
Yeah,
always has been,
and it's not going to change the way
they get them to random.
The Taliban is they give him Viagra.
That's the number one like,
yes,
yes.
They sit them down and yes,
the government's.
It's some down and they say,
listen,
we'll get you guns.
I have guns.
Get them out of here.
We'll give you women.
I have 25 so I can't even fuck them.
We can help you there.
That's what it is.
When I was there for 11 days and one of
the things I've talked to the marines,
you know what?
You know,
it's huge in Afghanistan.
Fucking boys.
Well,
no,
of these,
the forms.
No,
that's true.
that's true man.
I have a friend who went over there.
He caught a guy fucking the boy.
They all have like dishes,
they have satellite dishes and
satellite.
They should bring them porn.
Oh,
nice.
Fucking huge.
Because we're all humans.
We all want to fucking bang.
It's funny,
there was some,
you know,
everyone keeps on all these sama stories
are coming out and they're saying like,
people are saying that Osam was a huge
video gamer that he used to play guitar
hero.
Uh,
and so it's like all these bullshit
stories in our coming out would have his
children.
The one guy said it was a black belt in
judo and photos of no,
mother fucking.
I don't want to smoke his weed though.
I'm going to.
I bet
he's got some Joey Diaz.
We would listen to the news.
He'd have his children's stand by the TV
and when the music part would come off,
come on,
they would turn it down because he
wasn't,
he was,
he didn't want to listen to music.
It would corrupted.
That's how fucking career.
What a silly fuck.
The crazy thing is that he used to work
for us.
He used to be with the down with the CIA
and when we were training the mujahideen
to fight against the Soviets,
that motherfucker was actually,
he never took a paycheck from the CIA,
but he did.
Um,
he,
he was,
uh,
he did
himself open a lot of hospitals with his
own money and things like that during
the month during when the Soviets were
invading and,
and colonizing,
trying to colonize.
That
got to stop.
If you were going to have a story that
was going to.
I mean,
again,
you know,
the view that the world is a theater
played out for your own enjoyment.
If you were going to have this story
come to any conclusion,
this was,
this is the best conclusion ever.
Okay?
Because if this was a fucking movie,
all right,
if this was the hulk and the band guy
just died mysteriously in and they
dumped them and see,
they'd go,
okay.
And when you buckle up and the credits
would roll and he'd go,
fucking for sure there's going to be a
sequel for sure.
That guy is coming back.
They dump them.
And then they're going to show you how
he didn't really die and he can,
you know,
and then they fucking,
they knocked them out the back and shot
some other guy in the head and said it
was him.
Even the assassination was pretty bad
ass man.
They got it.
They had to come in there with three
helicopters if it really happened that
way.
When you hear about the Jessica Lynch
story,
you have to wonder,
man,
you have to wonder how much of this
story is true and how much of it is not.
If is it possible that they storm this
fucking compound?
There are a bunch of Islamic militants
there.
There are a bunch of bad guys.
They were looking for it.
They,
they kept these motherfuckers,
but there's no bin Laden.
They say,
all right,
here's what we do.
We,
we,
we know we're doing here.
We're going to take them a lot.
We've had them on ice for five years and
we're gonna.
Say we shot them and we're going to fuck
these guys up.
We're going to fuck up their mindset.
And they got to go.
He wasn't there.
We'd been looking for him.
He's not that we're,
we've,
we've been telling him this whole time.
Yeah,
they're there,
they're fucking hadn't been loud and
that's why we need to go to Pakistan
with these drones and Shoot Hellfire
missiles out of these drones to the
mountainside to fuck all these people
up.
It's because they've got bin Ladin.
Meanwhile
he's fucking dead.
We're telling you,
been locked up and get forever.
I haven't seen him.
Have you seen him?
I think it actually puts us in a really
tough position because now you've got a
lot of people asking very tough
questions of Pakistan saying you guys
didn't know he was there and Pakistan
has been our ally for the most part.
They're not really,
but they've,
they ostensibly been our ally because we
need them.
We,
a lot of our,
well they're friends.
We pay them to be our friends,
but the most dangerous country in the
world,
a lot of ways.
It's not.
They have 100 nuclear weapons and
growing and they've already given that
technology already to Libya,
North Korea and um,
uh,
the fuck else.
One of the people,
one of the persons and one of the group
of people and and to this guy a que con,
they had complicity with the Pakistani
military and there's no doubt that
Pakistan has its own agenda.
They were fucking.
They're terrified of India.
They use.
See,
here's the thing about us foreign
policy.
Nobody thinks about.
We have our agenda,
right?
We go in with,
well,
we're going to go into Afghanistan.
The motherfuckers that lived there and
around there and they go,
you guys are going to be gone in 10
years.
We got to deal with what's really going
on.
So you want us to be mean to the quote
unquote Taliban.
Like you said,
you know the Taiwanese.
It's the dude with the biggest fucking
guns and the most drugs.
Okay.
That she was going to be holding the
cards after you guys leave.
So after your centralized government,
that big experiment where you have
democracy in a country that's always
been a series of tribes,
you're going to tell me what,
what are you going to do?
Then we have to deal with that fucking
mess.
We got to deal with that law.
This area was aristotle,
etc. And that's what's funny.
They kind of just wAit and let us spend
a shitload of money and then they're
like,
oh look,
a vacuum and I just fill it up and it
goes back to normal.
That's the tough thing about foreign
policy,
man.
Yeah,
it's a.
It's a very tricky thing,
man.
It's a.
It's a very tricky thing to go nation
building.
It's a game,
isn't it?
well,
it station building is the dumbest game.
It's.
It's so clearly a resource game because
here's our biggest fucking physical
threat of safety ready Mexico.
It's right next door or you can fucking
drive there.
That life is worth a nickel.
It's in and everyone's selling drugs.
Goes back to what you said,
how we started this podcast.
You said telling your daughter to do one
thing.
She does the other you would think you
can nation build at the.
At the point of view from the barrel of
a gun,
you think you can do that.
You're going to tell people how to
behave the minute you come in there and
you're a foreigner who doesn't speak
their language and you're telling them
how to fucking live.
What do people do the minute they do
that,
they go,
get the fuck out of here and if I can't
shoot you,
I'm just going to keep my mouth shut and
when you're gone,
spend all your money.
When you're fucking gone.
I'm going to do whatever I want.
I'm going to do what I'm supposed to.
We only go places where there's
something that's the only place where we
go.
We pretend that there's these big
issues.
It's just like I said,
about the country of pfizer that
produces viagara.
If there was such a little land that
produced viagara,
we would fucking steal from them.
We would rob them.
Mexico has got tacos and tacos aren't
worth that much.
I,
I believe that the only thing that has,
the only thing that has resilience,
the only way,
the only thing that changes anything in
life and the only thing that has
resilience is ideas.
An idea is very powerful.
When an idea takes hold like the
constitution of this country or
whatever,
when an idea takes hold,
if an idea called democracy takes hold,
it'll fucking change and bring down
military dictatorships.
Take a look at fucking all of south
America.
It was all military dictatorships.
Twenty years.
The notion of democracy,
even as messy as it is took hold.
It was an idea that you just couldn't
fucking argue with.
That's by the way,
what's going on in the middle east,
this spring,
awakening with all these young people
who who could give a shit about islam.
What they really care about is having a
better life for themselves and their
kids and they want education and freedom
of speech and representative government,
which are human fucking rights.
You try keeping that now that that's out
of the box.
Just try.
Good luck to all the kadafi and all his
asshole is good luck trying to keep a
lid on that shit.
You're not going to do it because.
Because that's caught and they've seen
how the rest of the world lives.
They can see it with their computers and
their cell phones and you're never going
to be able to keep the fucking truth
down,
but the two points you can do it in
Cuba.
One,
the final vestige of that is North Korea
and those people are suffer so horribly.
It's sick,
but but that's the one place in the
world that's still somehow this,
this,
this tyrannical dIctator has the lid on,
but there is a,
like we were saying,
there is a tradition of freedom isn't
there?
But it's true that the cia is without a
doubt involved in orchestrating a lot of
these revolts.
I mean we.
It's not that these things are happening
organically.
Wesley clark in 2007 talked about the
United States plan and all these
different foreign countries and many of
them that have dictatorships including
Libya and he talked about the plans to
overthrow Libya and this was in 2007.
It's true,
but you know the,
the this spring awakening really
actually caught a lot of people on their
heels and especially a lot of middle
east experts because I think all you
need to do is push it and then it goes,
well,
what's that?
Well,
you know how it happened in Tunisia of
vegetable cart.
Guy got these.
Government officials came and they,
they.
This is how the whole revolution
started.
These,
these government guys said,
where's your license?
He didn't have a fucking license.
They threw a scales in the street and
they took his fruit and smashed.
You know what he did?
He fucking lit himself on fire.
Whoa.
And he lit himself on fire and protest
and that,
that proverbial match set off a fire
across the middle east and chooses judge
emotions.
this is the tunisians and the tunisians
brought down a dictator who I believe
had been in power for 25 years.
He came down and did his name.
His last name is ali,
and they brought that motherfucker down.
They brought that whole government down
because that kid lit himself on fire and
it caught fire in Egypt.
Take a look at Syria,
take a look at what?
I'm bashar al a door to door in Syria
right now.
They're,
they're,
they're being brutal because they're
fucking awful,
but while they're,
they're scared,
they're trainable in the fucking streets
and it's like the french revolution in
history keeps repeating itself.
How much of it you think is
orchestrated?
How much of this is just a.
Just natural that people are tired of
being fucked with and how much do you
think is the United States?
I think very little has to do with the
United States.
In fact the us hasn't.
We can't even get our reporters into the
Syria.
We can't even get reported right when
you hear it,
but you got like wesley clark is a
fucking,
what is your four star general running
for president?
And he says that the United States had
been plotting this.
We'd always been one.
The must have some influence on it.
I Think in the sense that we're trying
to.
Well,
I mean the,
the influence we had for example in
Libya was that we,
along with our nato allies,
said let's.
We can't allow the,
the libyan military to fly over these
rebel strong roles in these towns and
just carpet bomb the fuck out of him and
shoot him.
We gotta take.
We gotta create a no fly zone around
these people.
So in that sense we did get militarily
involved.
It was very controversial.
It still is very controversial,
but you know,
to an extent,
I think that democratic countries
starting with europe and this was
actually led by europe.
Uh,
the,
they,
they say what is in our national
interest,
is it,
is it still in our national interest for
khadafi or mubarak in Egypt had been
there for 30 years.
Is it in our national interest for that
guy to be in power?
There is a,
there is a convenience.
When obama was in power and you say you
can make a phone call to mark and say,
hey,
you gotta,
you gotta cooperate with Israel because
it's in our national interest.
Well,
that's no longer the case.
It's a different fucking ball game now.
It's a different ballgame.
you're having to deal with the arab
street.
You're having to deal with the will of
the people and uh,
that's going to be very interesting to
see how it plays out.
That's what democracy is.
And like I literally feel like I'm on a
political talk show.
I'm actuallY starting to talk that way.
So anyway,
blah,
blah blah.
You know,
when you read,
you read shit like confessions of an
economic hitman and you know,
you,
you see that we go only into countries
that have massive natural resources that
we want to stockpile and control.
It makes it very skeptical about
motivation.
It makes you very skeptical when you see
all the money that people spend on war.
And I'm not pro socialist,
but I am pro fixing problems and I think
I don't,
I don't believe necessarily in welfare.
Like I don't believe that if you give
people money that you're going to
somehow or another improve their life
because they're,
you know,
they were broke and now you give them
money and now everything's going to be
great.
No,
because you're going to develop a whole
culture that expects to get a check for
nothing.
And then when you have that,
you have no motivation,
you have no work ethic,
you will have no enjoyment and
satisfaction,
you have no productivity.
But I am for fixing schools.
I am for trying to develop human beings
that are going to contribute and I think
as a society and as a community and as a
culture,
that's one of the most important things
we can do.
Yet we Ignore that.
We all know this and we ignore that and
concentrate on boogie men on the other
side of the fucking planet where it's
quite obvious that this is transparent
game going on where these boogeymen just
so happen to only be where the gas is.
They just so happen to only be where the
oil is.
they just so happen to only be with a
heroin is.
I mean it's not that cut and dry.
It's
not.
But I think also that the.
The other question it raised is that
anytime you have a country with a lot of
natural resources,
let's just take oil which is traded
openly on the world market and that none
of us would go anywhere without oil.
And we all need it.
Uh,
if you look at the history of oil,
I'm not an expert on the history of oil.
I did live in Saudi Arabia for three
years,
but you,
you,
you look at the history of oil,
you look at,
you know,
in the middle east,
which was strategic because of that
resource.
The soviets and the americans were
obviously always fighting over who had
control of that,
that the,
the arabs for the most part created a
little something called opec and said,
fuck both you guys,
we're gonna.
We're gonna start.
We're gonna start controlling our own
idea.
But the idea of pan arab islam,
which is the notion that all the arabs,
that's what saddam hussein and those
guys and abdel nasser in Egypt try to
do.
They trIed to bring all the arabs
together under one banner.
It's never going to do that because
people are nationalist.
And people go,
I'm libyan first.
I'm not arab,
I'm living and I'm,
I'm egyptian.
You know,
and it just never worked.
But,
but,
um,
you,
you look at,
you look at how there was so much,
there was so much involvement.
And vying for those resources between
two,
two superpowers that of course,
of course shit is going to get crazy.
Of course when saddam was saying it
makes a huge mistake and invades Kuwait,
uh,
and we come to is,
we're not only come to his rescue,
but we use Saudi Arabia,
the land of muhammad,
that,
where,
where islam started and we were
launching planes out of Saudi Arabia to
kill other muslims for a guy like some
of bin ladin that was the equivalent of
slaughtering pigs in a synagogue for
those guys.
They were like,
you're out of your fucking mind.
We're now the imperialists.
Whatever you want to call them are
actually killing muslims from,
from,
from the original caliphate state when
you fucking know.
And that was one of the things that
radicalized him when the.
These are the kinds of things that
you're right.
I mean,
it,
there's always the cio has an idea.
They want to do something.
But when you say we,
by the way,
again,
it's a lot of different people in a room
that come up with an idea.
But let's just say,
let's just for the,
for,
for let's just simplify it and say the
cia or the us government at the time,
uh,
they say,
we want this,
this is our agenda.
One thing that they always talk about is
there's always circumstances that unfold
that none of us had any fucking idea
what happened.
It seems to be that's the way life is.
You got one plan and everything goes to
shit.
You know,
I mean,
you could make the argument by the way,
that the idea that we killed osama bin
ladin has raised a whole bunch of
questions.
A lot of people don't want to answer
from a political point of view.
So,
you know,
uh,
this is,
and,
and so it goes.
It's a verb.
What I was,
my point was not that,
why do we go to war?
Why don't we spend money on the things
that we really need to spend money on?
Why do we spend all this money on war?
We do,
we don't spend nearly enough do.
There's massive school cuts right now
that raises the class of massive school
cuts.
Right now.
There's fucking no community centers in
these,
in these bad neighborhoods.
There's no guide,
there's no counseling.
If you wanted to look at the one huge
problem that we have,
it's babies and children growing up and
becoming shitty human beings because
there's no love because there's not
getting any help and they're at.
We're not putting money in that at all.
The question of disproportionate amount
of money we put in the military budget
and compared to how we treat children in
this country and raise kids and work on
terrible communities and work on
educating and getting people out of bad
situations and you say,
oh,
well,
you know they're going to figure it out
on their own.
You don't have a fucking clue what kind
of a disproportionate life you'd be
living if you were born in the ghetto.
If you've ever been around the projects.
Have you ever been around terrible
neighborhoods?
I never lived in a really bad
neighborhood,
but I lived in Jamaica plain in boston
and it wasn't good by any stretch of the
imagination and there was a lot of
really poor people around me,
but we would go into really bad
neighborhoods.
We would go to buy pot,
we would go to do dIfferent shit.
We would go just because it was
dangerous,
you know,
we were young kids.
We're close to bad neighborhoods.
There's people lIve in it in ways that
you can't even wrap your head around and
there's not much ways out of there.
You're you're there and you're golf.
Tomorrow is a classic example of how
about fucking detroit?
We're 50 percent of the people can't
read.
It's unbelievable.
That's a real statistic that just came
out was actually 47 percent,
47 percent.
You can't say that.
That's an even playing field and you
can't say that for the human race.
That doesn't need to be addressed and
helped.
Absolutely,
and it's not a mountain getting welfare
mothers money so they can keep shitting
out kids.
It's about helping the fucking kids.
The welfare mother might already be
fucked or programming might already be
jacked.
She might already be on some downward or
you know,
the addiction spiral,
who knows,
but you can help that kid,
you know,
one of the things that always raised
with social scientists as they say,
there are a lot of cases in this country
where were you through a lot of money at
a problem.
Let's take headstart as an example.
And,
and uh,
or,
or just a lot,
a lot of the money that bush spent on
education,
which was a lot of money over the past
eight years.
Why in the world didn't a lot of test
scores in certain segments of society.
They didn't budge and sometimes they
went,
they went down and you spend all that
money.
Those teachers aren't making shit.
You're spending the money the wrong way.
The money is being spent too much in
this area.
Then not that,
not that area.
And that's the challenge of a
government.
That's the challenge of a bureaucracy.
You your tax,
you have a lot of money trying to find
out how to spend that money and where to
spend the money.
It's always been a challenge for a
proportion of that.
Money is the problem.
The proportion is tiny compared to the
problem.
It's tiny.
The salaries that teachers get is
unlivable and that is a really important
part of being a human being.
If you look back on your teachers that
you had and how much they influenced you
and how much power they have over you.
This is the person who stands in front
of the class and tells you how the
fucking world works and when you're a
kid,
that's a huge,
huge responsibility that many times is
bestowed on idiots.
It's bestowed on idiots and they took
this job because they couldn't get
another job and they're fucking,
by the way,
try tribe with the teacher's unions and
then just try getting.
Just try firing a teacher who has tenure
because they've been teaching for three
years and a lot of districts just try
now in the high schools they get tenure
like so hard to find our schools.
yes,
it is so well there's a docuMentary
called waiting for superman,
but forget that there's an article just
now in the New York times about about.
I'm trying to get a.
I think it was in the state of Ohio,
just trying to get one law passed one
law,
one law that makes it harder for a
teacher to get tenure or easier to hire
a high quality teacher in place.
If someone was not performing,
you weren't dealing with fucking 65
different interests with a lot of
lobbying power.
Starting with the teacher's union.
That also then has a subsIdiary called
the chicago teacher's union that has a
subsidiary called the county teachers
union and you're dealing with fucking
the reality of trying to make a law go
through.
Holy shit,
man.
Holy shit.
Talk to a senator sometime.
Say,
hey,
I want to get a law passed and it's a
simple one.
Talk to him and see how long it takes
and how many years and how many people
you got to pay off and how many people.
You got to convince them you have to
have a homicide because a lot of people
go.
The problem with the law as two things.
You pass a law,
it does one thing.
It puts a whole bunch of people out of
business
and a whole bunch of other people in
business and any law you pass doesn't go
away in this country and you know why?
Because a whole cottage industry grows
up around that law.
That's why.
Oh yeah,
we've talked about that many times.
Especially when it comes to drugs.
I mean there's a reason why people are
still trying to keep marijuana illegal.
We have more than 50 percent of the
people in prison today in this country
are in prison for nonviolent drug
offenses and there are a tremendous
amount of private prisons in this
country.
We're on pain.
It's a business and we have to wrap our
heads around the fact that there's some
sort of a creepy situations happen where
there's a lot of money and keeping
people in jail and because of that there
are make no doubt about it.
The prison guard unions and all these,
you know,
various law enforcement unions,
they're not lobbying to keep marijuana
to make marijuana legal.
They don't want it at all because it's a
part of their economy.
It's a part of their,
their whole system situation that this
is what happens in life is know a lot of
people have a vested interest.
That's why being a politician or a
president and that the old saying,
when you're a president,
you make,
you make one decision,
you,
you make 50 percent of the people happy.
And then another 58 percent of people
out there hate your guts.
It.
There's no way to avoid that when you
have power tenure.
Tenure for a teacher is almost.
It's has some of the elements of
intellectual,
um,
welfare in a great way to put it in
that,
you know what I mean in that it sounds
like a good idea.
Like what you're gonna do is you're
gonna make it so you can't get fired.
So you are allowed to be free with your
ideas and you don't have to worry about
the repercussions of your,
of your free thinking.
And this is gonna promote thought,
but the problem with that is when you
know that you can't get fired,
you become a client.
And that's just what people do.
It's natural.
It's just like,
well,
I was doing standup and I think it was
Kansas city.
I talked to a principal that came to my
show.
I said,
give me your take on the education
system.
They said,
education system's fine.
I said,
what do you mean?
He goes,
education,
my school is amazing,
but you know what the problem is
parents,
a lot of parents suck.
They suck.
And a lot of it is this culture that
doesn't put a premium on education and a
lot of places.
The idea that you gotta work your
fucking ass off against insurmountable
odds for anything.
All that stuff.
I mean,
you know,
well kids in where we live with an even
trickier element,
there's this fucking weird escape clause
where you can become famous for nothing
and then you get millions.
And so instead of working your ass off
for almost nothing after taxes,
you look at kim kardashian who just fuck
somebody and makes a video of it.
And then gets a tv show where they
follow her around,
she does nothing to contribute,
she's not saying anything,
but yet she's making millions of dollars
and good for her.
You know,
I'm not hating on her good for her,
but to kids that all of a sudden becomes
this goal,
this weird fucking weird like clause in
the contract.
Since we're little escape clause and a
few people find it and they,
they get through the system and all of a
sudden look at this person making
millions of dollars for it.
Kim kardashians made something like
$60,000,000 last year.
Fucking insane.
It's crazy money.
You know what I mean?
She's an.
Every time I go to the fucking airport
and I throw my keys in the bin,
I see her in some sketches ad with her
fat ass ticket out and she's wearing
some sneakers.
It's supposed to make you fast though,
by the way.
I like her.
I said even real,
totally real lever.
Breasts are real.
But really?
Yes,
I think you'd believe in santa claus to
mother fucker carb.
That is my type,
but she's always getting her face carved
up.
Why don't you?
Yes,
she is.
There's been a bunch of photos.
Any credentials.
You're crazy.
You haven't seen the photos?
No.
Dude.
You got to look online.
You're going to make them.
You made a mistake or face all puffy.
Looking like a cat.
woman was like right after she had a
procedure pond.
Yes,
without a doubt.
And I had to them make makeup.
I worked with her on how I met your
mother and she wouldn't give a fuck
where you work.
She looked.
LIsten,
pal.
This tossed girls had,
had to start like this girl is a blast.
Exert who?
Without a doubt.
And you know,
whatever man.
I mean,
if that's your business,
your business is staying hot.
I guess.
What you gotta do what you gotta do like
26,
right?
She's fine.
She's delicious.
Let me see like that.
What are you doing?
You're looking for the photos here.
We'll uh,
we'll find them and I'll show them to
you later because this is going to be a
pain in the ass.
But what my point is,
you and I have both talked about this
and I did get out of here for a little
while,
but moving to somewhere where that's not
an influence.
Is that even possible anymore though?
Because that influence is sort of like
all over the country now.
I don't know.
I,
that's a good question.
I think though,
at the end of the day,
you're still gonna have a lot of people
who hold on to what's important because
life is basically a kick in the nuts and
it's going to teach you that shit.
You know,
you still got to compete.
You've still got to fight gravity.
You still got to find fulfillment and
accomplishment.
And the only way to accomplish something
like a black belt in jujitsu is fucking
roll all the time for four or five,
six or seven or 10 years.
If you want a black belt,
that's what it takes.
If you want to know that you truly are,
you know somebody that can tie somebody
in a knot.
And I'm speaking metaphorically in
anything.
It takes a long fucking time.
You want to be a Good stand up.
You want to be.
You want to make people laugh all over
the country.
I'll see in 10 years minimum.
I mean in a way,
if you're lucky in a way life is going
to life kind of sorts itself out so
people worry about I think.
I think it's always been,
well these people are,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know of any story in the world
or any leader in the world.
It didn't complain that his followers
for the most part were retards and,
and,
you know,
oh,
to change and get people to understand
what's important.
That's what every religious leader of,
from from christ on,
for moses,
for god's sake,
5,000 years ago,
why my people don't know what's
important here are the commandments.
You pagans,
you know,
it's always been that.
It's always been people who are older
always been like,
you fucking kids are partying too much.
Stop with all the fucking,
the drinking,
the booze and then,
and you know,
and,
and the drugs.
Here's what's important.
Yeah,
if you don't,
you're going to get struck down by
lightning.
So the I'm going to scare the shit out
of you for your own good.
Right?
And ultimately all of these things are
in place so that we can have this
society so that people can survive so
that people can keep breeding so we can
continue doing what doing,
which is sort of centers around
technology,
social animal.
We've alwaYs,
we've always had a war with nature
anyway.
That's kinda like what we're the only
animal that has a symbiotic relationship
with an artificial life.
And that artificial life is technology.
You know,
you could say technology is not alive,
but I mean we use the word evolution to
culturally earlier use the word
evolution for machines and if you look
at simple machines that were around,
you know,
50,
60 years ago and you look at the complex
machines now with the microchips that
are powering your fucking cell phone.
And we're where this is all headed in
some sort of a weird direction.
We are inexorably connected to this
technology.
Wouldn't inexorably inexorably connected
to this technology.
Inevitably in our society is connected
to.
I mean this was what the unabomber was
terrified about.
This is when he took his manifesto.
Technology will get to a point where it
no longer has a respect for its
biological heritage.
People can say it's not a live forum.
It's not a life form.
You're right.
It's not.
There's no blood in it and there's no
tissues cells,
but what is it?
It's something that's growing in a va.
You can say that it's not a life form,
but what is it?
A fucking human being.
A human being iS some sort of a weird
biological computer that's riddled with
bacteria.
That's what we that with synthetic dna
coming up with.
We're not just living,
we're coming up with living.
We're coming up with manmade bacteria
basically,
and you know,
this is one of those conversations that
inevitably when whenever we have this
sort of conversation on the message,
on the podcast,
on my message board,
someone will come up and go this fucking
bullshit stoned hippy talk.
It's always some aggro fuckhead with a
poor argument and they get upset about
it,
but the the bottom line is with all this
hippie talk is,
you know,
everyone's like,
why are you thinking about that?
Why are you thinking about like,
well,
where's it all going?
We're just all going,
man.
It's going nowhere.
Shut up,
go to work.
The reality is that something is
happening and for whatever reason we
have an instinct to ignore it.
It's not hippy talk anyway.
By the way,
you think a tippy talk,
take a look at what computer scientists
are talking about.
Computer scientists and scientists in
general are talking about evolution in,
in terms of human beings can control and
are controlling their own evolution,
so it's not hippy talk at all.
In fAct it's called hard scientific
talk.
It is cold outside dog,
but it's also still radical theoretic.
It's also stoner talk.
It's also the kind of things but the.
That's why we did so awesome you fuck,
but as we started talking in 20 years,
we are going to like it or not have to
contend with tech,
technological advances that are,
that are so far beyond what most of us
are dealing with today.
Biocompatible technology,
things that fit into your body that make
you remember fast.
Keep you awake longer.
Placement parts.
Heinz bionic,
man,
bro.
Sure.
So,
so,
so these are realities that are going to
affect how you make a living,
what you talk about,
what you listened to,
what your children are influenced by.
So anybody who thinks they can stay out
of this debate or even this discussion
is kitten themselves.
Man,
you're kidding yourself.
He does have an air of silliness to it.
It's got an air of man.
You know there's something to it when
you're considering,
you know,
these,
these really fantastical possibilities
and probabilities of the exponential
growth of technology.
It does have this sort of silliness to
it.
That's kind of where we're spiritual
conversation comes in with the notion
that yes,
we have all these technical logical
advances,
but the same old questions that a human
being's going to have to answer for
himself are still gonna exist sort of
one way,
you know,
I wonder if it's there for the same
reason why when your dick is hard,
you don't even think about putting a
condom on.
you just stick it in there because.
Because yeah,
just whatever,
just getting up,
fuck.
I made a kid.
It's almost like it's designed that way
and our,
our mass,
you know,
the,
the huge percentage of the population is
not thinking about the eventual upcoming
technological singularity.
TheY're just not.
And,
and if you bring it up,
it's like,
oh,
right,
right.
But I wonder if that's there for the
same reason.
It's the same sort of an instinct that
makes the hard dick stick it in without
a condom to make sure it happens anyway.
It's like this crazy instincts.
Oh fuck,
you just don't come and tell me.
Okay.
Okay,
well shit.
You know,
it's like,
it's almost like it's engineered into
reasonable.
Whenever you start talking about if it's
a guy gets up and says,
well,
climate change and sea levels are
rising.
You talked to me about that talk,
talk to me.
I go,
that's too big to think about and I
don't have any way to cool the fucking
planet,
so I'm going to change the channel right
now.
I'm walking away.
But when you talked to dopey republicans
about all will only tell you something
about these liberals.
He's liberals in their climate control
now.
they been going on and on about the
climate control.
There's what we know ladies and
gentleman,
we know that the climate has changed
since the beginning of time.
It's cyclical.
Okay?
Don't get in the way of big business and
big industry.
Okay?
Because there's a reason why the United
States of America,
he's doing show.
Well,
there's a reason why you need this
economy to turn around and it's not
liberal,
so it's not a god damn sitting around
with tambourines and a circle around a
campfire singing grateful dead songs.
Okay?
Anyway,
all right,
we'll be right back.
You know what I mean,
and you get into that.
That's read that right wing rhetoric
idea that you know,
like,
ah,
god got settled down.
Hippies,
you know what it is.
It allows things to happen,
and it also,
it also stops the debate.
It allows you to stick your dick in
without a condom because you're silly.
Did the instincts are to fuck things up.
The instincts are to make more people.
The instincts are to continue the
technological progress regardless of
what fucking effect.
It doesn't matter.
This is human history is one.
The one constant in human history is
that people were never able to see
catastrophe as a group through world war
one,
world war ii famines,
the black plague.
It never.
We are not good at predicting major
fucking issues and events,
whether it's a tsunami all due respect
to the people in Japan or anything like
that.
We'll eventually not good at doing that.
Well,
we haven't gotten a lot better.
It used to be and say,
hey,
by the way,
there's an.
There's a 20 percent likelihood that a
huge earthquakes about to hit and the
next week that I'm sure we'll get better
at doing stuff that we will use to be
that you didn't know a tornado was
coming until it killed you.
You have no idea.
you had to see it go,
oh shit.
In 2000,
11,
300 plus people in Alabama and our
country,
there's nothing they can do.
There was nothing they could do about
that.
Have you ever seen the the destruction
photos online?
I tweeted them there.
They're insane to tuscaloosa.
Alabama was literally wiped off them.
I've never experienced in any way a
nature's force like that.
That must be so crazy.
Terrifying.
Yeah,
and the crazy thing is it happens every
year.
There was something like 400 fucking
tornadoes this year.
We were in a house and it gets,
it gets ripped apart and you're in the
house.
Like,
you know when there's a rainstorm and
you hear thunder,
you're like,
let's,
let's cut it off in front of the tv.
That's my reality,
but here's the thing.
I would fucking mood.
Have you ever been in a hurricane?
No,
I've been in a hurricane,
but the hurricanes that hit the east
coast up in the boston area,
by the time they got up there,
right?
Not so much.
Not that big a deal when you're in the,
in when you're in the middle,
when it starts,
when you're in the fact that whatever
they call it,
the eye of the storm,
that's not the start.
The start is the eye is the center.
When you fuck up and you go,
well,
it's over and you step outside the air
force guys who fly into that shit,
that shit to test all the kinds of nutty
there in the middle of a fucking insane
is that because any other plane comes
apart,
any other plant comes apart,
they come apart and stuff.
If you're a pilot,
my dad was a pilot for 20 years.
When you're a pilot,
you fuck and worry about thunderstorms.
If there's thunderstorms that is death,
you don't scare a thunderstorm and scary
shit.
Doesn't matter if you're a seven,
47 or less.
guys just fly right into it.
They fly.
Why don't we make all planes out of the
same shit they make those other plans
because you can only have two or three
passengers and to make it awesome would
be if you were in a plane.
He knew it couldn't break.
this coin is never going to crash.
It flies in a fucking hurricanes and
shit.
It's made out of the black box.
I heard,
I heard the craziest stupid old hack j.
now it's.
I heard that the craziest hippy a theory
lately.
I read somewhere today that if you have
a birthmark that's where you were
murdered in a past life or killed in a
past life.
Is this from a girl that you're trying
to bang?
No,
I read it on facebook or something.
It's kind of interesting.
I would have been stabbed in the back of
the head and the interesting.
If you have brain damage people always.
That's why you good experiment.
But what about fucking redheads or
stabbed everywhere?
No,
no.
I have a.
Gorbachev was shot.
Shot to the body.
When you and I were talking about that
you blew up the internet.
Is that when you can get facts right
away,
like factcheck the thing is like what?
Before that,
you know,
we all just would just start saying shit
like that.
Start saying anything.
Here's what I know and this is the truth
and being,
why'd you do some checking?
Like I didn't leave recently.
I've been going back over my archives of
the shit that I believe and say.
And I'm like,
oh,
that's a big hall there.
Unfortunately.
The last time you Were here,
there was one.
the ones one about the wiki leaks.
Wiki leaks,
one will.
You unfortunately said that about that.
Everybody.
Wikileaks,
apparently they did remove names of all
the people to protect the people.
Accept people who are no longer with the
cia or whoever were with and you know
they were already exposed.
Yeah.
The wiki leaks thing is a very tricky
situation,
man.
You know,
they're,
they're going after that guy,
his guns blazing because I like
transparency,
but I don't know.
I don't know,
do know of the 12 we have bp
whistleblowers,
all the 12 people that came forward
about all the problems in the oil
disaster.
Nine of them are missing,
including people murdered people.
One guy who survived and assassination
attempt.
It's really kind of freaked me out a
heart for bp to that.
That was a hard thing to cover off.
Is it the whole ocean?
Well,
here's a good way to cover it up.
Shoot everybody who knows anything and
it seems like that's actually happening.
I need to this one site that had it,
I put it up on my twitter and it's
getting crushed.
I can't get to it anymore.
Um,
but uh,
there's,
there's something going on.
I don't,
I don't know if it's true or not.
I need to,
uh,
I need to find out about this because
it's pretty fucking fascinating.
The bp exec.
Yeah.
I got confused yesterday.
I was driving down the alley and there
was these three girls.
It's walking down the alley.
Like I was like,
come on,
get the fuck out of the way so I can
drive by.
and they were like 15,
16 year old girls.
All of them just stopped and then
flashed me,
like pull down their own.
They,
they moved me to pull down their pants,
all three of them in burbank and it in
the back of an ally in the back,
like they were fully.
Yeah,
they were fucking around.
Like,
I have an alley in my neighborhood.
There's alleys,
so I'm driving or something.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just driving and I'm just like,
they're,
they're walking in front of me.
Like I'm like,
come on,
get the fuck out of here.
And suddenly they just all stopped,
pulled down their pants,
moon me and ran away by the fIrst
second.
I was just like,
oh my god,
it's a wait.
If there's a broken bitch out there,
brian will find you.
And I did that to brian will find her
like a magnet to little metal particles
named mark core was named Mark Ward.
You know joe?
Of course muslim.
But he was,
he was at my house and he was walking up
the stairs.
I go,
come here,
I want to show you something.
Come upstairs.
Because he had just gotten to la to come
see my one hour and and as he was
walking on stairs unit,
I was like kind of a state guy and I and
I,
I was bent over with my ass wide apart
and as he walked up the stairs and he
just goes,
he goes,
oh,
what's that?
And he,
I think he went,
what the fuck?
The same thing you said when you saw
dixon feet.
Listen to out of the 12 people in
question that we're the bp
whistleblowers nine and mysteriously
dead one nearly died in a brutal
assassination attempt.
One is imprisoned under questionable
circumstances and another has simply
disappeared.
You don't.
Yeah,
I don't really believe that either.
And that guy in the questionable
circumstances where question will tack
brian,
don't talk from the other room.
You fucking freak.
Go piss.
How ridiculous is this guy?
Trinity screaming.
So after that happened,
after that happened,
I was in such shock and I was going to
starbucks.
I was in such shock and so were in shock
because some girls moon to you.
I mean that's pretty crazy.
Seeing three girls butt holes and
vaginas that are under age and you're
just driving around like minding your
own business.
So I get of my car and I go and see you
actually see they're buttholes and
vaginas or did they have their legs?
I remember it so that,
you know,
I remember at least one of them I saw
the like,
you know,
like the,
the whatever.
So I,
I,
I'm like thinking about them.
I'm like,
what the fuck was that all about?
And I walk in and there's alan alda,
is that his name for mash?
Just staring at me like this.
Like he knew that he was just shaking
his head was so weird
talking about,
I don't get it.
I walked into starbucks and now now that
it was and he was staring just staring
at me.
But it was like,
right when I walked in and was like,
holy shit,
this is the weirdest.
I was super high when all this
ridiculous conversation or you should
have started off this conversation by
saying,
oh hi,
you were because you're like alan,
all those staring at me.
And he was like,
and that was like really freaking out.
Like what the fuck kind of a
conversation that we have in here.
What the fuck?
What kind of story is that?
It's what happened to me yesterday.
We left out the most important part.
This is one of the reasons why pot
should be illegal.
NoW I'm on the other side of the fence
where we are,
but here's what I don't believe right
now.
Here's what I don't believe in.
I don't believe in psychics.
I don't believe that corporations like
bp have anything to do with like are
able to pull off murderers or any of
that state
or murder or based on oil and all wars.
Pretty much how loud?
It was tough in brisbane.
It wasn't based based on oil necessarily
alone.
Actual outlet because you left it on all
week and it's going to blow the fuck up.
Go war made the oil more expensive and a
lot of ways.
So I don't know why because they're
making more money.
Those cons you have,
but they're not the ones that nine slash
11.
Is that how things work you?
You say that too,
but how can you say that with any level
of certainty?
That's ridiculous.
I can say it with a lot of level of
certainty.
The same way I can tell people camper
corporations are working when there's so
many instances of corporations killing
people,
they all have different.
They all have different agendas is all
I'm saying like if you're.
If you're a bank,
you have a different agenda and watch a
movie and you're competing against
another bank and there's a movie where
someone is trying to make money and
something goes wrong,
and then they hire a hitman and jason
stage.
Right?
Based on what?
Based on human fucking nature.
We know it's possible.
We're not talking about super powers.
We're talking about someone having
someone killed because it would cost
them billions and billions.
We don't think it's possible boardroom.
You've got to have a problem wIth this
bp story is it has all the elements of
an internet hoax.
You know?
I mean it's,
it's fantastic.
It's it's unresearched bubble and I'm
trying to research it and it keeps
telling me that all those investigative
journalists out there from all those
newspapers are always looking for a
story.
I wouldn't be all over that.
Believe me,
they would be all over that.
Yeah,
maybe.
But thIs is.
This is sort of like some kind of shit
that you have to be really,
really,
really sure about the.
You're not going to get this published
in time magazine.
You lie on your,
on your podcast to bring a reputable
investigative journalist on this show so
we can talk about about what a new
hello,
reputable investigative journalists I
want you to do.
This is called the volcano and what's
inside here is marijuana vapor.
It's way better for your lungs.
Have him come in here.
Those are.
This is legit,
bro.
We're ranked on itunes.
Really?
Number two are,
you know,
it's always number one or number two was
number five and joe rogan does.
Doesn't surprise me.
Journaling has been a Winner,
my friend.
And I love you.
I love you too,
but I think it's a weed.
I'm not that high.
I'm telling you bro,
because I think your thing is too hot.
Really
smoking it too much.
Sorry.
Yeah,
you might.
I'm going to kill them.
Volcanoes.
Very tricky.
Some guy just got life in jail for his
third.
We'd,
um,
third.
We'd have never going to be this on
camera and we're going to build one for
fourth.
Fourth marijuana conviction gets
slidell.
Louisiana may have life in prison.
He's a repeat offender.
And by this,
a refeed burpee defender,
the jury found defendant guilty of
attempting to possess and distribute
marijuana.
Dude was selling weed and they put them
in jail for life,
for life.
And he's 35 years old.
That's ridiculous.
Terrible.
It's a tragedy.
It's the only way pot kills you.
There's two ways.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
What was the all four times the same
thing?
They,
it sounds weird.
All right.
That guy deserves to be in jail.
I'm thinking after the second or third
time.
All right,
dude.
Just fucking start funding like in a
different job for selling weed,
dude.
And you know,
the,
the law is unjust.
It's unjust.
Retard is.
Yes.
Definitely had the brightest guy in the
world,
but what he's doing,
he's not hurting anyone or do we have
too many fucking laws?
You don't feel bad for him because it's
not yo,
dude.
No,
it easily could be one strike anything.
I can.
If you have for duis,
I think you deserve to be fucking.
You're just a fucking retard.
If this guy is selling for duis are
dangerous,
you're hurting people.
You're scaring me.
It doesn't matter this brian that
matters.
It matters.
It matters,
but it also matters like this guy's been
in trouble three times,
two times.
Okay,
you're right,
but your giving in,
you're giving into the man.
You're.
You're saying whatever law rules that
you make is illogical as they are.
I'm going to fall back on because I
don't want to get locked in a cage.
What I'm saying is there's no way you
should be locking someone in a cage for
that.
It doesn't make any sense,
and if someone does that,
they're the criminals.
When you have a society,
a complex society with a massive amount
of access to information and literally
you can find the answers to any question
instantly on your phone.
When you have a law that's in place
that's completely illogical,
like marijuana laws and then you
prosecute people for them and then you
lock them in jail.
You are the criminal.
You are the one who's going against
logic and nature with all your fucking
silly studies.
Ron paul just own some motherfucker the
other day on,
on the senate floor and it was.
The guy Was talking about marijuana.
He said he thought heroin should be
legal.
He ron paul,
just clown them about personal use,
freedom of use,
and if heroin was legal,
do you think we'd all be using heroin?
We just.
I mean it was so.
It was so on the money man about all of
it.
We need less fucking laws.
All you people out there that are
involved in this industry of laws and
industry of,
of creating jobs that,
that are attached to laws.
Your leeches,
your this is leeching off society.
It's a fucking loophole.
And if we got rid of that loophole and
forced everybody that has some shitbag
jobs for locking people up for pot,
we would force those people to have more
productive lives because they would have
to evolve.
I think you would have to contribute.
I think that more than any other time in
our country's history,
the,
the discussion about legalizing drugs is
very much alive.
And even polIticians like ron paul who
have a growing following are,
are being taken very serious,
slowly evolve fast enough drugs not fast
enough or logic or my taste.
It's not not changing enough in my
lifetime.
It is changing.
I mean the,
the climate here in California
especially is really revolutionary.
If you drive down the street near my
house,
there's fucking five.
We'd stores in a one block radius ratio
area.
It's,
it's really data that is incredible,
but it's not changed enough.
There's still plenty of fucking morons,
silly ideas about forcing people into
other.
There is a reason why the United States
is not competing with the rest of the
world as far as things we produce.
It's because a lot of people aren't
producing shit.
They're just a part of some weird
fucking system,
some weird system.
It's a very weird system that doesn't
necessarily make any sense.
Our financial system doesn't necessarily
make sense.
Our,
our,
our are,
uh,
we're not,
we don't really produce anythIng.
You know,
putin said it best when he was analyzing
United States economy before the crash.
He said,
I don't understand the american economy.
All they seem to be doing is buying and
selling each other's houses.
And he's right.
What the fuck else do we do anymore?
We make mustangs and camaro's and
corvettes and a couple other things.
We have a comparison.
Very powerful.
Um,
military.
No,
no,
no.
I'm,
um,
comPuter industry.
I mean we do that innovation,
art in medical innovation and stuff like
that.
We got a lot of stuff.
It could be argued though,
that if there were less laws and they
were more freedom and there was less
people in these fucking bullshit
parasitic government jobs that those
people would be forced to contribute.
Maybe they would become cabinet makers.
Huge.
Great argument.
Maybe they'd become authors.
There would be.
They would contribute.
It is a form of social welfare to have
shit jobs that aren't necessary.
They.
There was a great article in the wall
street journal about how a lot of
states,
three out of one job,
our government jobs,
not not private sector jobs,
manufacturing jobs.
When you hear like the government
created new jobs and you know what a lot
of those jobs are surveyors,
weird fucking government exemptions that
are unnecessary and build anything
that's not what made this country great
bureaucrats and you're absolutely right
and it is a form of social welfare
because if you give someone a job and
make it so they don't have to find their
path.
It's like I've always said that the
greatest thing that ever happened to me
when I was 21 years old,
I played the lottery once.
I won a free ticket,
but I played it again.
I want nothing and then I was done.
I said,
I quit.
That's it.
What if I was 21 and broke and scared
and lost and I won the lottery.
That would have been the worst curse
ever.
I would have never found my way in life,
and if you get some shitty fucking easy
government job you can't get fired from,
and then that becomes your life.
Well guess what?
You're not going to find your place
either,
man.
You're just going to.
It's a form almost of social welfare.
We need less,
less of everything.
That's where I got like ron.
Paul's on the fucking money,
man.
That ain't that bad motherfucker.
That guy.
Oh,
he's the best.
And the other guy,
Gary Johnson,
the former governor of New Mexico,
same thing.
She just stand up at a great point.
He said,
I like him.
He goes,
same sense less jesus,
but I don't mind.
I don't mind ron paul's diseases.
I don't mind any of it because the way
he talks is the way,
which in my mind is America when my mind
is,
here's the deal.
He believes in personal freedom and
responsibility and allowing people to
make their own choice.
It makes the call on what is really
going on and why we're invested in all
these different parts of the world and
what we're really doing.
He's honest about it and he was saying,
this is not what America should be all
about,
and he says that all the time.
This is not what this constitution was
supposed to mean.
It's not what our founding fathers
wanted.
This is the way this is supposed to be.
The best example possible of what you
can do with this society.
This is 2011.
We've learned from the greeks.
We learned from the romans,
we learned from the nazis.
We learned from everybody.
We've got it down,
but we don't.
We don't and we don't and it's
transparent how we don't.
It's all there.
Every time,
like the obama recently pass on fucking
new law about genetically modified food
and it's going to fuck over all these
organic farmers.
Man,
this shit's been going on for awhile.
Monsanto's involved in a lot of fucking
creepy shit,
man,
and the government has been behind all
this.
It's a good book though about about that
and we're again,
when you talk about technology and
monsanto and these other companies that
do genetic engineering,
the only way we're going to feed the
growing population is through genetic
injuries.
True.
Now there's a way to do It.
There's a bad way to do it.
Obviously it comes with risks.
It also comes with a great deal of
promise,
but genetic engineering is in all of
your future,
whether you like it or not.
The real problem has toiled to farm
organically and feed all the people in
africa,
for example,
etc. Etc.
Right?
But isn't the real.
The real problem is sustainability,
but the real problem is also that you.
You get to own that.
You own a plant and monsanto is
inherently.
They're there.
They're trying to,
first of all,
they tried to patent pigs.
Do you know it's going to be a lot of
that and they're going to figure this
out in the courts.
But the bottom line is this.
One thing that none of the promises of
genetic engineering is that we will
maybe never have to use any pesticides.
And if you want to talk about
agricultural runoff,
that's one of the biggest forms of
pollutants and all our waterways.
So for example,
if you could come up with a kernel of
rice,
an apple that requires no spring because
in it it has genes that are not only
incredibly nutritious,
but that can ward off any kind of a
pest.
That's something that is going to be in
our future.
It doesn't come with risks is are there
problems are.
Do you do.
I feel weird about taking the,
the gene of a jellyfish and putting it
into a strawberry because it actually
keeps it from freezing.
So you can ship it farther.
Yes.
This is where adam corolla would come
in.
What we got here.
It's going to be great in about 10
years,
right?
You don't want to get in on the ground
floor.
You don't want to get in here with all
this genetic engineering.
You want to wait?
Let me see if that's what he would do.
Oh,
by the way,
we told them that.
What you said too about the improV.
He actually repeated it,
repeated it to us and said that he was
the happiest he'd ever been.
And you made him so happy.
And I concurred.
I said,
you know,
I brought it up.
I said,
brian cowen said this,
and I think he's absolutely right.
He's the best at tying together as long
rants and making them work.
If I,
if I listened to him,
I can get him.
I could start doing my act and he's got
it.
He's got a uh,
you know,
one of those things.
I think it was that.
Yeah,
he's that smart.
It kind of norm macdonald's and he's an
interesting guy,
man.
I really,
I really liked him.
Smart guy.
He's very smart.
He's very smart and in a very unique and
interesting way.
My buddy box,
very honest.
He's got heavy hands.
He says,
I really.
Yeah,
he's a good boxer.
See the movie the hammer?
No,
it's all about him being a boxer.
Well,
I know he's in the ring and he's,
he's apparently,
he was a boxing trainer for a long time
too.
That's how I made a living in hollywood.
Yeah,
he's a good dude,
man.
I really liked that guy was a very
unusual thinker and a,
and an unabashed gearhead.
I love that too.
I loved cars,
man.
I hate when people pretend like I've run
on some guy's thing,
shitting on someone for being middle
aged and buying a sports car that it was
such a midlife crisis sort of thing,
and I was like,
god,
what a silly way to look at that.
How come he's not?
how come he's not just an enjoying the
fun of anybody who's a gearhead because
it's a passion.
It doesn't have to be in anything
rational and logical about it.
It's a passion.
So some people are born with the
wrenching gene at the random forest of
the wrenching jane.
Jane and I don't like it.
I'd rather have somebody else to do.
I'm.
I have the driving gene,
but I Want someone who knows what the
fuck they're doing to fix my shit.
You have to drive.
You always loved.
I love cars.
I'm well.
I'm first of all,
I'm a technology fanatic.
I'm obsessed with it.
I've always been obsessed with any new
gadget.
I remember the first time I saw pong I
was.
I was obsessed with it.
I couldn't believe that soMeone had
figured out a way to make this move.
Something on the tv was one of the first
people I ever met who had email and
stuff like I was like,
oh yeah,
what's his email thing that I had a
computer in [inaudible] 94 and I didn't
send an email to anybody until like 98.
Nobody had fucking email though.
I never got it now.
I hardly ever talked to any of my friend
Amy Patton oswald and I've been going
back and forth on twitter.
I'm supposed to call them,
but I'm like,
can I actually have to call somebody and
make her go back and forth to talk about
a funny dude I love his writing was one
of my favorite guys as far as like
taking a premise and this beaten the
shit out of it and he's going into all
sorts of weird ways with it.
He's.
He's a really interesting guy.
I liked him.
He was a writer on mad tv when I.
When I first started this,
it really was a part of the original
cast.
He was there and I enjoy his cds.
I think he's my favorite guy to listen
to you and have sketch ideas on the wall
and one was one was just explosive
diarrhea and then the other was feeling
kind of rapey.
We were,
uh,
when we were doing mad,
the man show that was one of the most
fun things is to put a pump a bunch of
ideas and try to make some duty that I
do that with my writing.
Do you do that?
see I have a board up there.
I do that with my,
my act now and I take a photo of it on
my iphone and then when I'm in a hotel
room and I want to go over my notes,
I just look at the photo and you could
get expanded.
so I move it around and iT's easier than
turning pages.
It's technology man.
It's making it all easier.
But uh,
I think writing something down and like
putting it up there for you.
There's something about creating when
you write things down and then put it
into like a little box and then stick
the box in the wall and step back and
look at it as like,
instead of like being on top of it,
writing it and being immersed in the
words to sit,
put it on the wall and step back.
Really,
really successful.
Screenplay writer I've ever spoken to
does exactly that.
They really sIt down and write real,
real wow from Alan Ball who I talked to,
who wrote american beauty,
who I talked to about how he starts his
scripts and stuff and he said character,
but you know,
but any of those guys,
all of them,
todd phillips,
they,
they outlined the shit out of it.
They see it up on a board and I don't
know,
one director or one right.
Or certainly not one screenplay writer.
Not one who makes it fortune.
Uh,
who,
who was a successful screenplay writer,
a professional who doesn't do that.
I just started doing it recently.
I've been writing forever.
It's the way to do it.
That's why a lot of people write a
screenplay and then they just end up
running out of steam or it doesn't quite
work.
There's a.
there's a real sort of structure and
technique to writing.
You see,
even novelists,
novelist will lay it out,
man.
I mean john irving for his last book,
took seven years to write that book.
Seven,
think about the act of faith that would
require because it had to be thematic.
He created these characters,
very autobiography,
a book a year in the mystic river,
a one year in the scripture,
I believe it's called.
What is it about a.
It's very autobiographical about silicon
goc.
No,
john irving is that.
Not everything is.
It took them seven years and it's always
about blown dudes by the river.
Black cod
turns this in.
This is.
Have you read.
Have you read any of his books?
No.
No dude,
I can't believe you haven't read genre.
You know what,
dude?
I kind of stopped reading fiction a long
time ago.
I started reading some Joe Hill
recently.
I stopped leaving.
Kingsborough.
Yeah.
I started.
I started reading it again because it's
fun and I realized I was reading too
much creepy shit.
It was almost like what I was talking.
I'm going to writing a whole bit about
it in my act now about the apocalypse is
not,
you know,
it's here,
but it's not here.
You know what I mean?
like what I said earlier,
the way I phrase it,
it was the first time I ever phrased it
that way,
that it's here in the sunnier,
but I'm writing this whole,
this whole big chunk about that and so
it's forcing me.
I'm constantly reading all this nutty
fucking shit about the world and I'm
like,
god damn it.
This is not that fun.
Like you can.
You can freak out about fucking
supermassive black holes and super
volcanoes and you could freak out about
the shifting of the polar ice caps and
it really doesn't make life any more
interesting.
But if good werewolf movie comes out,
you know,
life is fun for like a fucking hour and
a half.
You know what I'm saying?
if you pick up a good.
Joe hill is stephen king's son and he's
a.
He's a writer as well.
Yeah,
he's a good dude.
He's good.
I got it.
I read just.
I'm almost done with heart shaped box.
Great.
fucking scary shit.
It's about a guy who was a rock and roll
star,
like some creepy marilyn manson who buys
this a dead guy's suit online because
it's haunted.
It comes with a ghost and he thinks he's
being accused,
so he buys this dead guy suit.
I don't want to say any more about the
plot because the plot is brilliant,
like how it's all established and set
up,
but it's a fucking page turner and it's
so much more fun than comedy and michael
rupert book about the collapse of
civilization.
You know,
smoking cigarettes,
collapsed documentary.
have you ever watched you want to shit
your pants.
Watch that collapsed documentary.
What is that?
it's michael rupert.
He's this guy,
used to be a former la cop who busted
the cia selling drugs in la
neighborhoods and went public with it
and eventually left the police force and
was told that he was supposed to let
these people go and it caught them and
he's,
you know,
very,
very vocal about it.
Always worried he's going to get
assassinated.
Well,
thAt started as downward spiral of doubt
and doom and now this guy is.
He's got a whole fucking documentary
where he was sitting there smoking
cigarettes,
talking about how the society we're
going to run out of oil and society is
going to.